Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten, mein Name ist Tim Prettler und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer weiteren Ausgabe und äh auch diese ist äh im Rahmen meiner,
Reise über die kanarischen Inseln entstanden und ähm ja, nachdem wir uns zuletzt äh noch einmal Exoplaneten genauer angeschaut haben,
tauchen wir jetzt äh etwas tiefer in das Universum noch ein, ja, noch tiefer. Heute wollen wir uns nämlich unterhalten über die Beobachtung von Galaxien und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner. Helmut Dannhauer, hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Helmut, du bist genauso wie der Hans-Jörg Dick, äh auch beim,
Astrophysico de Cannarias, also hier der lokalen und wahrscheinlich auch einzigen Space ähm ähm,
Entität oder? Gibt's noch äh eigentlich eine andere außer dem IRC, die hier noch in irgendeiner Form einer Raumfahrt arbeitet?
Universität gibt's noch Leute aber die Universität ist auch mit uns.
Dann, ne.
Richtig, aber genau astronomisch ist das sage ich mal das einzige Institut. Auf den Kanarischen Inseln.
Ja du bist beobachtender,
Astronom. Also du schreibst dir die äh Sachen ganz genau an, natürlich nicht äh mit dem bloßen Auge, sondern eben mit vielen Teleskopen.
Teilweise denen, die hier auf den kanarischen Inseln platziert sind, aber auch anderen, da kommen ja noch zu. Mich würde natürlich jetzt erstmal interessieren, wie bist du überhaupt
äh hierher gekommen, auf die Kanaren beziehungsweise wie bist du denn überhaupt auf den Weg gekommen einen äh Astronom zu werden?
Physiker.
Astrophysiker zu werden.
Genau, also wie ich ein kleines Kind war, hat mich eigentlich immer schon die Welt rum fasziniert, also Space Shuttle, das habe ich dann eben mitverfolgen können und.
Mondlandung habe ich jetzt nicht mehr mitbekommen, aber ich habe natürlich über die Berichte darüber gelesen und das hat mich eigentlich immer fasziniert.
Dann wie ich mir dann eben Gedanken gemacht habe, was ich studieren äh möchte. Eigentlich hatte ich die Idee, wie Informatik zu machen, aber irgendwie hat mich,
also vor allem das Buch von Stephen Hawking eine Reise der Zeit, das hatte mir ein Kollege wie wir dann das Abitur gemacht haben, der hatte mir das geliehen,
dann gelesen und das hat mich so fasziniert, dass ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, ob ich nicht doch ähm Astrophysiker werden sollte. Ich war dann auch äh vorm Studium in Südamerika unterwegs mit dem mit dem Rucksack.
Dann vom Weiten die Teleskope gesehen, ich konnte die dann leider nicht ähm besuchen, aber,
dann ist immer mehr in mir der Wunsch ähm ja wie soll ich sagen hat sich entwickelt, dass ich halt eben das probieren möchte aber in Deutschland ist es halt eben so also man macht da nicht äh gleich eine Ausbildung zum Astronom oder Astrophysiker. Man muss halt eben Physik studieren.
Und.
Im Hauptstudium kann man sich dann eben halt auf verschiedene Bereiche der Physik spezialisieren, zum Beispiel Halbleiter Physik und ich habe das dann eben auf der Astronomie-Astrophysik gemacht. Ich habe an der Ludwig Maximilian Universität von München studiert. Die hat eben auch einen sehr,
ähm eine Abteilung in Astronomie hat, eben auch dann eben vor allem in München ist auch ein sehr bekannter, weltweit bekannter Standort in der Astrophysik,
eben zum Beispiel die Eson, auch eben verschiedene Max-Planck-Institute. Und dann dachte ich halt eben schon, dass es dann vielleicht doch eine gute Umgebung für mich, dass ich.
Ne?
Richtig, dass ich halt dann weil oft als Student sagt man ja als Student da bleibe ich nicht in meiner Heimatstadt, sondern gehe woanders hin, aber da dachte ich teilen in dem Falle wäre das jetzt vielleicht ähm doch ähm ratsamer dann in München zu bleiben.
Und habe dann eben das Studium aufgenommen, Physik,
und im Hauptstudium dann eben habe ich dann eben verschiedene hm astronomische Kurse eben belegt. Habe dann auch eben verschiedene Themen äh Gebiete auch kennengelernt und was mich dann eben auch fasziniert dabei halt eben Galaxien.
Und ich habe dann eben auch äh während meines Studiums ähm meinen späteren Doktor Vater, den Herrn Professor Reinhard Genzel eben kennengelernt, der hat eben auch eine Vorlesung gehalten.
Jüngst mit einem Nobelpreis ausgestattet wurde.
Genau richtig und es ging halt eben auch über Instrumentierung. Das war halt eben Teil davon des Studiums, sondern das hat man wirklich äh sehr gut gefallen, seine Vorlesung.
Ich habe ihn dann einfach drauf angesprochen, ob's eine Möglichkeit gäbe, bei ihm eine Mastarbeit zu machen und er meinte dann, ich sollte mir mal dann
die Webpage anschauen von seiner Arbeitsgruppe, was es so alles
und es hat mich vom ersten Moment, hat mich einfach kollidieren, die Galaxien einfach fasziniert und es gab dann eben dann auch ein Projekt, das war verbunden mit Beobachtungen in Chile, die teilweise schon genommen worden sind mit einem vier Meter Teles,
aber es gab dann eben auch noch äh Beobachtungen durchzuführen. Ich habe dann eben da meine Masterarbeit gemacht, also damals hat das ja noch Diplomarbeit geheißen.
Das hat dann eben alles ganz gut geklappt und da war auch eben mein Wunsch, dass ich dann auch eben dort die Doktorwelt mache. Und dann habe ich halt,
Zuerst in der Maßnahme habe ich halt eben Galaxien, ich sage mal so, im lokalen Universum beobachtet, also sie relativ nahe zu uns sind und in der Doktor Band ähm bin ich dann halt eben zum frühen Universum gesprungen.
Und warum ging's dann bei der Doktorarbeit.
Bei der Doktorarbeit ging's darum eben auch,
verschmelzende Galaxien zu beobachten, aber halt, wie gesagt, halt eben im im frühen Universum, die sind dann auch mit einem Instrument von der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, von Institut für Radio-Eustromie, die sind halt eben,
entdeckt worden. Das waren halt dann auch neue Galaxien. Im Rahmen meiner Doktorarbeit war der.
Instrument ist das entdeckt.
Mit einem 30 Meter Teleskop im von Ayram das ist 'ne in Spanien in der Nähe von Granada das sind die eben entdeckt worden in einem
in einer Durchmusterung, in einem Service und unsere oder meine Aufgabe, der Doktor war halt eben dann diese Galaxien zu charakterisieren, deren Eigenschaften ja zu studieren und auch eben vor allem die Entfernung von diesen Galaxien zu bestimmen.
Hat es dann eben auch angefangen, dass ich dann eben nicht nur äh mich auf einen Wellendenkbereich ähm spezialisiert habe, also den Radiobereich, wo die äh entdeckt worden sind, sondern ich habe dann eben auch angefangen
Beobachtungen im Optischen und auch im verroten Bereich durchzuführen. Und ich hatte eben auch das große Glück,
dass ich halt dann eben auch selber die Beobachtung wirklich durchführen konnte. Ich konnte eben dann eben auch nach Chile fahren, nach Hawaii und eben mit den verschiedenen auch mit den größten Teleskopen, die es so gibt halt eben zu beobachten.
Und jetzt bist du hier seit.
Seit 1. April 216 und ich bin hierher gekommen mit einem sogenannten Ramon äh Stipendium.
Stipendium von der spanischen Regierung. Das gibt's halt eben in in verschiedenen Fächern,
Es ist fünf Jahre angelegt. Also man kann halt eben auch wirklich seine eigene Wissenschaft äh durchführen. Man hat auch ein kleines,
Starterpaket sage ich mal, von 40.000 Euro für Reisen und auch Equipment.
Und die Idee ist halt eben dahinter auch von diesen äh Stipendium, dass es halt so eine Art
Track ist, dass man eben danach dann wirklich eine feste Stelle in der Wissenschaft bekommt. Also ich habe davor in Österreich gearbeitet. Ich war eben schon über zehn Jahre Postdoc
Und irgendwann sagt
normal, man will den nächsten Schritt machen und ich habe dann eben in einem in meiner Zeit in Wien schon gesagt, wenn das jetzt nicht mit meiner ähm mit einer Stelle klappt, wo es dann eben Aussichten gibt, halt eine feste Stelle zu bekommen.
Dann lasse ich halt das Ganze, dann war's das halt eben, aber ich hatte eben das große Glück eben, dass es ähm Stipendium zu bekommen, das auch sehr kompetitiv ist.
Dann sind wir halt mit der ganzen Familie halt hier nach Teneriffa gekommen und Gott sei Dank hat es auch eben alles gekla,
und seit äh Dezember vergangenes Jahres bin ich auch äh Beamter hier am Institut.
Also Ziel erreicht und äh nebenbei noch schönes Wetter äh im in der Dauerbespielung.
Ja, genau richtig. Also ich komme ja aus München und ich bin wirklich sehr heimatverbunden, aber was ich nicht so gerne mag, ist der Schnee und hier gibt's ja nur den Schnee, wenn man zum Tede hochfährt.
Ja, oben aufm Vulkan, genau und den auch nur äh ab und zu mal.
Ja du bist hier so ein bisschen die äh als Galaxien äh Jäger äh sozusagen bekannt und ähm.
Das ist also der äh Fokus. Den Fokus wollen wir dann jetzt hier auch ähm mal ähm in Angriff nehmen
Es gab schon mal eine ausführliche Sendung zu Galaxien und Kosmologie im weiteren äh Sinne. Das ist so ein schöner Überblick gewesen, wie man
ob da auch erstmal diese Begriffsklärung in den Kopf zu kriegen, die er vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer jedem
klar ist, so wo endet ein so ein äh Sonnensystem, wo beginnt äh quasi die Galaxie, wo endet eine Galaxie, äh wie stehen mehrere Galaxien miteinander in Verbindung und auch äh,
wie dunkle Energie.
Dunkle Materie, alles das, was äh dazukommt, das gibt's in Raumzeit dreiundsechzig. Markus Brücken unterhalten habe. Heute wollen wir uns ein bisschen mehr äh konzentrieren auf die Galaxien als Zeuchen.
Und ähm da ist ja eigentlich auch in den letzten Jahrzehnten eine ganze Menge passiert durch die Verbesserung der der Teleskope,
natürlich durch Hable, aber eben auch viele andere Beobachtungsmethoden, die einfach immer besser schärfer, tiefer, weiter äh gucken konnten und vor allem durch äh auch das Auffächern der Beobachtungs ähm
Bandbreite, indem man halt einfach nicht nur im optischen Bereich äh das äh auch von unseren Augen wahrnehmbare Licht äh anschaut, sondern Radioastronomie, Infrarot, Astronomie, was alles noch mit äh
dazukommt und wie sieht's hier auch in den letzten Sendungen schon mehrfach angeklungen ist und das spielt für dich ja auch eine Rolle, auch das James Web Teleskop wird gerade in diesem Bereich glaube ich,
Ja dann scharren schon alle mit den Füßen. Du wahrscheinlich äh ganz besonders oder?
Ja, also ich war jetzt erstmal froh, wie viele meiner Kollegen, äh dass der Staat gut geklappt hat und da habe ich mir dann eben auch damals geschaut, es war der erste Weihnachtstag.
Meinen Kindern zusammen angeschaut und es hat alles gut geklappt und habe dann auch eben immer wieder verfolgt, dass jetzt sage ich mal das Deployment von dem TSG gut klappt mit mit der Reise und vor allem was ja wirklich der spannende Moment war,
dass es halt eben auch alles klappt mit den mit den Sonnensegeln, aber den eben auch ähm das Ausklappen des Teleskops und es sind ja viele Prozesse, was ich gelesen habe, ich glaube mehrere hundert, die wirklich.
Über dreihundert.
Dreihundert, die wirklich Singlepoint Fehler waren. Also wenn's da schief geht ähm.
Alles das gewesen, genau.
Richtig und das ist ja schon wirklich eine eine absolut ja bemerkenswerte Leistung, dass das alles so toll geklappt hat,
und jetzt hoffen wir mal, dass dann eben auch die das sogenannte Commissioning der Instrumente alles gut klappt, also wird in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten werden dann eben die Instrumente getestet,
und dann hoffentlich nach nach sechs Monaten, also ja im Sommer, dass wir dann eben die ersten wissenschaftlichen Daten halt äh nehmen von den verschiedenen Beobachtungsprogrammen.
Ja, das waren alles,
gute Nachrichten und ich glaube die beste Nachricht obendrauf war ja dann, dass insbesondere die Injection, also der eigentliche Launch, so gut funktioniert hat, dass man sich so dermaßen viel Spritz,
hat, dass äh die Missionsdauer von 20 Jahren jetzt äh durchaus realistisch erscheint, davon konnte man ja nicht unbedingt ausgehen. Das macht natürlich nochmal einen Riesenunterschied.
Ja auf alle Fälle, also es hat ja immer geheißen, dass es jetzt erstmal fünf Jahre ist und bis Maximum zehn Jahre, aber,
Ich hatte davor auch nichts großartiges äh mitbekommen, dass wirklich das wenn das alles tatsächlich so super klappt auch mit der Ariane-Rakete halt eben, wie die eben äh das Teleskop in den Umlauf bringt, dass man dann äh
so viele Jahre gewinnen können. Ich habe vor paar Wochen habe ich mir ein Webinar angehört, angeschaut äh über James Web, da wurden halt eben
verschiedene wie soll ich sagen Verantwortliche von den verschiedenen Instrumenten und auch Prozessen
eben Vorträge gehalten oder habe ich dann die eben das auch erfahren, dass das halt eben, wenn alles gut klappt, also äh ja bis zu zwanzig Jahre im im Orbit sein kann und das habe ich Base Teleskope ist ja auch schon 30 Jahre eben,
im Ohrbett und ja das ist schon eine eine tolle Nachricht.
Da macht sich das Geld dann doppelt und dreifach bezahlt und es ermöglicht natürlich auch ganz andere Beobachtungen, weil man natürlich am Anfang erstmal oft all das schaut, wo jetzt alle denken so, oh, da müssen wir unbedingt mal hingucken und dann ist halt vielleicht auch noch Zeit äh auf all das zu schauen, wo man dann äh später eigentlich erst draufgekommen ist.
Ja, die Beobachtung von äh Galaxien ähm.
Warum ist das so interessant, abgesehen davon, dass dich das interessiert? Also gibt es da sozusagen
spezifische Lehren, die man jetzt konkret aus der Beobachtung und dem Wesen von äh Galaxien äh im Gesamtverständnis des Kosmos äh ziehen kann oder ist es halt vor allem einfach äh eine,
eine komplexe singuläre Disziplin, die halt auch durch werden muss.
Wir möchten halt eben äh verstehen, wie die Galaxien sich gebildet, unentwickeln.
Zum Beispiel unsere eigene Galaxie, das haben wir jetzt eben in den letzten Jahren, ähm also auch festgestellt, dass eine sogenannte Balkenspiralgalaxie.
Wir möchten die Vergangenheit schauen, möchten verstehen, wie sich die Galaxien äh so entwickelt haben, wie wir sie jetzt im lokalen Universum beobachten. Und was ich ja eben habe vor fast 100 Jahren eben ja gezeigt,
ist, es
ja nicht nur Spiralgalaxie wie unsere Milchstraße, sondern es gibt eben auch elektrische Galaxien. Und man will halt eben verstehen, warum gibt es zwei Typen von Galaxien? Es gibt da auch noch sogenannte irreguläre Galaxien.
Und deshalb ist es eben auch wichtig ähm zurück in die Vergangenheit zu gucken und zu schauen, wie die Galaxien früher ausgeschaut haben.
Und es gibt auch ähm bei den äh Entwicklungen von Galaxien gibt's eben auch das Modell mit dem hierarchischen Merching.
Eben von kleineren Blöcken, Komponenten, immer größere Galaxien stehen.
Typen von Galaxien muss man denn so auseinanderhalten? Also wie äh wie funktioniert da die Klassifikation derzeit schon? Also klar, Balken, Spiralgalaxie, also Spiralgalaxie. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Spiralgalaxie ist ja so so die prototypische,
Form, die man, glaube ich, so primär mit Galaxien auch erstmal,
verbindet äh vermutlich deshalb, weil die erste Galaxy und lange Zeit auch einzige Galaxie, die man überhaupt so richtig sehen konnte, die Andromeda Galaxies, die ja quasi
nicht die nächste, aber die nächst größte Galaxie ist oder ist es sogar die allernächste. Ich bin mir grade nicht ganz sicher, dass die kleinen Magelanschen Wolken und so weiter, ne, die sind.
Genau, das wollte ich sagen, richtig, das sind ja irreguläre Galaxien. Genau, die margianischen Wolke, die große und die kleine Wolke. Das.
Brauchte man erstmal eine Weile bis man verstanden hat, dass es eine Galaxie. Das war ja auch bei Andromeda äh so, aber die ist dann sozusagen in ihrer ganzen Erscheinung. Es ist ja eine reine Spiralgalaxie oder ist es auch eine Balkenspiralgalaxie?
Soweit ich weiß, das ist eine Spiralgalaxie.
Genau, so das ist äh also sozusagen so dieses typische Bild und man ging, glaube ich, auch lange Zeit davon aus, dass die Milchstraße dann genauso aussieht, weil so sehen Galaxien eben aus.
Richtig
wir können ja leider keine Sonde hochschicken, die dann Foto von von der Milchstraße von oben macht, aber man hat halt eben durch Vermessungen der Bewegung von Sternen oder wie halt die Sterne eben positioniert sind am Himmel, hat man halt eben dann in den letzten Jahren etwa 20 Jahren eben rausgefunden, dass es halt eben keine
Es ist natürlich eine Spiralgalaxie, aber es gibt halt eben noch ein ein Balken äh in der Galaxy erleben.
Ist schon klar, worum's diesen Balken gibt.
Also ich weiß, dass jetzt äh nicht so ganz genau, weil ich an dem Themengebiet äh nicht dran arbeite.
Mhm. Okay. Aber das sind auf jeden Fall, nachdem man dann eben immer weiter äh schauen konnte, mehr Galaxien äh gefunden hat, mittlerweile ja weiß nicht wie viele Galaxien mittlerweile katografiert sind. Ist ja irgendwie eine Größenordnung, Millionen.
Ja mindestens 100 es gibt mindestens 100 Milliarden Galaxien.
Ja. Okay. Die auch schon alle eine Zahl haben oder ist es die Schätzung, wie viel es gibt vermutlich.
Ja, das das ist das ist eine Schätzung, wie viel es ungefähr gibt.
Okay, gut und ähm wie stellt sich das so dar, wie normal ist so eine Balkenspiralgalaxie, wie normal ist, sondern Spiralgalaxie ist das so, das, was man meistens findet oder sind das auch nur zwei oder vieren?
Nee, also im im lokalen Universum findet man schon der Großteil der Galaxien sind halt eben Spiralgalaxien, also reine Spiralgalaxien und halt eben dann äh Balkenspiralegalaxien.
Halt dann eben immer weiter in der Vergangenheit äh schaut, ähm dann entdeckt man halt eben.
Immer mehr Galaxien eben nicht so wie eine Spiralgalaxie ausschauen, sondern eben auch irregulär sind oder nur eine reine Scheibe und keine Struktur haben, wie sie wie wir das halt eben in unsere Galaxy zum Beispiel sehen.
Mhm. Das heißt, man könnte annehmen, dass eine Spiralgalaxie zwar sehr verbreitet ist, aber eigentlich erst so die zweite oder dritte Stufe ist, nachdem sich sehr viele Prozesse äh erst haben, entwickeln können.
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Mhm. Wie zum Beispiel Kollisionen, aber nicht unbedingt nur Kollision.
Ja also äh Kollision ist zum Beispiel schon ein wichtiger Treiber von von der Entwicklung von Galaxien, also zum Beispiel,
eines von den Modellen, was man eben kennt ist oder von den Beobachtungen eben auch abgeleitet hat, ist dass man dann eben zum Beispiel zwei Spiralgalaxien hat.
Eben dann eben auch die Verbindung mit elektrischen Galaxien. Also man hat zwei Spiralgalaxien,
und die kollidieren die verschmelzen dann miteinander und die sollten ungefähr etwa die gleiche Größe, die gleiche Masse haben und danach bildet sich halt dann eben eine elektrische Galaxie daraus.
Was dann eben im Laufe der Zeit passieren kann, ist mit dieser lipischen Galaxien, dass die Gas äh akretiert von der Umgebung und daraus bildet sich dann wieder eine Scheibe.
Oder auch auch Spiralen und dann später kann diese Galaxie mit einer anderen Scheiben oder Spiralgalaxie mit dann miteinander zusammenstoßen, bildet sich wieder eine elektrische Galaxie.
Okay, also es ist gar nicht so ein Endzustand, sondern das kann sich eigentlich permanent immer wieder durch äh tauschen über die Zeit.
Ja genau richtig, also zum Beispiel auch mit unserer eigenen äh Galaxie. Da gibt's ja auch äh sage ich mal schlechte Nachrichten. Ich glaube eins, zwei Milliarden Jahren gibt's da auch einen Zusammenstoß mit der Andromeda.
Andromeda, genau. Wobei Zusammenstoß muss man sich nicht so vorstellen, dass dann irgendwie alle Sonnen aufeinander knallen und irgendwie äh explodiert, sondern da berührt sich wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Ja genau, das hatte ich gerade im Kopf. Ich habe da mal ein Beispiel gelesen gehabt,
klar denkt man vielleicht im ersten Moment, dass da die Sterne dann miteinander zusammenstoßen wie die Planeten und und und wie auch immer, aber ich habe gelesen jetzt beim zum Beispiel Zusammenstoß von der Milchstraße und der Spiralgalaxie ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass zwei Sterne zusammenstoßen ist, als wenn man zwei Tennisbälle in Deutschland irgendwo hinlegen würde.
An dieselbe Stelle.
Irgendwo halt den also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die zwei Tennis besser an der gleichen Stelle sind, die gehen ja gegen null, sage ich mal.
Ja, Space ist big. Das äh kann man immer wieder daraus äh ablesen,
Okay, das ist also grundsätzlich, wenn man jetzt in die Beobachtung macht, man hat also entweder diese olympischen Galaxid oder man hat,
Spiralgalaxien in der ein oder anderen Ausprägung mit oder ohne Balken äh und dann äh hier und da auch mal irgendwas, was dann beiden Beschreibungen nicht wirklich entspricht, aber irgendwie,
Nur ein heilloses Durcheinander ist. Kann man das so in etwa zusammenfassen.
Ja so also vor allem eben im frühen Universum. Also es gibt dann eben Galaxien wenn die dann zusammenstoßen auch hatte. Die haben dann zum Beispiel auch Gezeitenschweife. Das kann man eben beobachten oder halt man man kann in die.
Ein Gezeitenschweif?
Also wie gesagt, man hat äh zwei Galaxien und die interagieren ja über die Gravitationskraft,
und ähm wie gesagt, die verschmelzen ja miteinander und durch die Gravitationskraft werden halt eben in die Stirn und das Gas sage ich mal auseinandergerissen und dadurch entstehen halt eben dann die sogenannten Gezeitenschweife.
Also Gezeiten im Sinne das Spiel der Kräfte.
Ja genau richtig, die Gezeitenkräfte richten.
Dann kann man halt eben schön beim beim manchen Galaxieren zum Beispiel es
eine Galaxie, die nennt sich NGC 40, achtunddreißig neununddreißig. Das ist die sogenannte Antenne Galaxie. Das sind halt eben auch zwei ähm Spiralscheibengalaxie miteinander zusammengestoßen und da gibt's ja wirklich,
Bilder, wo man halt dann eben zwei Gezeitenschweife sieht. Die schauen halt dann so wie eine Antenne von so einem Insekt aus. Aber man sieht halt dann eben auch noch den Kern von den Galaxien. Man sieht auch noch so ein bisschen das blaue Licht von den jungen Sternen und in
in dem Zentrum von den zwei ehemaligen äh Galaxien sind wir halt dann eben auch äh die Röhrensterne, die halt im in der sogenannten Verdickung in dem Ball steht eben auch sind, also,
Galaxien, die haben wir vor allem eben auch äh nur alte Sterne, dass halt eben vielleicht auch zu betonen, also Spiralgalaxien da rotieren ja die Sterne.
Um das Zentrum rum, in einer elektrischen Galaxie ist es halt eben äh nicht der Fall.
Da gibt's halt ist halt einfach ein olympischer Körper, der kann eben verschiedene Elektrizitäten haben. Da werden eben
Galaxien auch klassifiziert nach der gewissen Elektrizität. Und dann gibt's, sage ich mal, ein Zwischending zwischen äptischen Galaxien und und Spiralgalaxien, das sogenannten S null Galaxien.
Ach, weiß ich gar nicht, wie das jetzt auf äh auf Deutsch heißt.
Saß er auf Englisch.
Ich glaube Galaxien
Die haben halt praktisch den Ball und haben auch noch eine gewisse ähm Art von Scheibe, aber haben halt noch keine Spiralstruktur und die sind halt eben wie gesagt
so ein so ein Zwischen äh Schritt zwischen elektrischer und und und den Spiralgalaxien und vielleicht auch das Interessante ja vielleicht zu erwähnen ist
Also Veapel eben auch das äh Modell halt eben erstellt hat ist, dann gibt's halt eben die Early-Type Galaxys, das sind halt eben die elektrischen Galaxien, da gibt's die Late-Tech Galaxien, das sind halt eben die
Spiralgalaxien, aber wir haben halt eben auch jetzt rausgefunden, dass ich halt eben auch aus Zusammenstößen von Spiralscheibengalaxien halt eben da eine Lippischegalaxien, also eigentlich die Late kommen vor den.
Also es ist so permanentes, galaktisches äh Billard, nur dass es eigentlich selten klack macht und äh permanent ändern sich ähm die Strukturen dieser äh Galaxien nichts nichts nichts bleibt äh äh wie es ist. Umso interessanter
ist es ja dann in die äh Zeit äh zu schauen. Mich würde jetzt vielleicht erstmal deine
Arbeitsmethoden interessieren. Also was ist sozusagen das das Rüstzeug, womit äh arbeitet man jetzt als beobachtender Astronom, wenn man sich die äh Galaxien anschaut,
Klar, erstmal braucht man Gerät so, aber dann muss man ja auch mit den Daten noch irgendwas machen. Also welche,
Teleskope, welche Instrumente kommen jetzt deiner Arbeit äh konkret zum Einsatz?
Also um halt eben die Entwicklung von Galaxien,
gut verstehen zu können, ist es halt mittlerweile sehr wichtig, einen sogenannten äh zu machen, also eben in verschiedenen Wellenlängen zu beobachten, also wie ich halt eben vor 20 Jahren mit meiner Doktorwelt angefangen. Da war doch eher noch der,
Astromina Infrarot, wie du erwähnt hattest oder auch Radio Astromie und Röntgen-Astromie.
Ist es halt eben wirklich notwendig, um halt die Galaxien gut zu verstehen, dass man halt eben verschiedene Wellenlängenbereich eben abdeckt, um halt eben dann verschiedene Prozesse miteinander verbinden zu können und auch wirklich äh zu verstehen auch interpretieren zu können.
In meiner Arbeit halt eben, also hier in in Teneriffa oder auf La Palma haben wir eben das Grandikanteleskop, das ist ja das größte optische Telesko,
der Welt verschiedene hexagonale Spiegel, die halt eben zu so einem größeren Spiegel, ich glaube zehn Komma vier Meter dann ähm zusammengefügt worden sind, also ich verwende zum Beispiel auch eben für meine Arbeiten eben das Grande Cantelesco, weil eben
Beobachtungen
Darüber hinaus äh verwende ich dann auch zum Beispiel auf der spanischen Halbinsel des ähm Ayran ähdreißig Meter Teleskop, das ist ein Radioteleskop.
Was halt dann eben auch vor allem also kalten Staub beobachten kann, eben auch äh molekularen Wasserstoff,
auch wichtig äh zu erwähnen aus molekularen Wasserstoff entstehen dann eben erst die Sterne.
Äh welche Frequenzbereich schaut sich also für welchen Frequenzbereich ist das Teleskop gemacht, dass es das tun kann?
Dieses 30 Meter Teleskop in bei beobachtet zwischen 80 Gigahertz bis zu 250 Gigahertz, also etwa drei Millimeter bis ähm ein Millimeter.
Es gibt halt eben eine eine sehr wichtige Linie. Das ist ähm Kapern äh Monoxid.
Das ist ja, kommt er auch an den Abgasen von den Autos rauf? Also hier ist es ein bisschen giftig aber für uns Astronomen ist es ein sehr wichtiger, hm wie soll ich sagen, sehr wichtig ist Tool, eben um halt eben rauszufinden, wo zum Beispiel
Gasreservoires äh sind, wo dann eben auch ähm Sterne entstehen.
Da verwenden. Man kann halt eben molekularen Wasserstoff halt eben aufgrund seiner physikalischen Eigenschaften jetzt im Radiobereich nicht direkt beobachten.
Man macht das halt dann eben indirekt eben über Kapern äh Monoxid.
Und genau und die Linie, die ist halt eben bei 150 Gigahertz, also das ist so aus eine der wichtigsten Liene, ist halt der Übergang eins zu null,
und klar mit der Rotverschiebung
ist es dann halt dann eben verschiedenen Frequenzbereich und dann beobachtet man halt eben, sage ich mal, wenn man jetzt bei 150 Gigahertz beobachtet, aber es ist halt dann eine eine andere Rotverschiebung dann beobachtet man dann auch eine eine andere Linie zum Beispiel. Also wenn das jetzt zum Beispiel Rotverschiebung zwei ist,
Würde man in diesem Bereich bei etwa hundert Gigabs nicht mehr die eins nach null, sondern die drei nach zwei Linie B.
Ein bisschen zu äh dekodieren. Also wir reden ja jetzt von hier von von äh der äh Spektroskopie, das heißt, man man schaut sich das Licht der Sterne äh an oder in dem Fall der ganzen äh äh Galaxie und bricht es halt in seinen Spektralen
Bestandteile auf, aber dazu muss man eben auch einen entsprechenden Quellfrequenzbereich überhaupt erst mal äh anschauen, um dann eben,
speziellen Marker zu sehen, die eben ausgelöst werden, wenn dieses Licht eben durch die Stoffe, nachdem man sucht, äh,
naja, wenn man sich das Licht von beliebigen Sternen anschaut, kann man halt sagen, okay, alles klar, da ist jetzt irgendwie so viel Helium und so viel Wasserstoff und äh alles dabei. Wenn man jetzt nur sozusagen ins ins kalte Nichts äh schaut und so nach Stäuben, also wirklich so geringsten Anteilen äh blickt, dann muss man eben sehr genau äh hinschauen, dass es jetzt sozusagen eine dieser Methoden, die man mit
diesem Teleskop machen kann.
Genau, zum Beispiel, das ist halt eben ein sogenanntes Single des Teleskop,
Und was sage ich mal der Nachteil von von diesen ähm äh Single Distiliskoben im Radiobereich ist ja, dass er die Auflösung, die hängt halt eben von der Wellenlänge ab.
Hängt er natürlich auch von der Größe vom Teleskoper, vom Durchmesser, eben auch von der Wellenlänge. Und Oma,
dann eben auch Beobachtungen im Radiobereich mit denen im optischen Einbruch, wie zum Beispiel vom HPS Base Teleskop miteinander zu vergleichen. Wäre es sehr wünschenswert, dass man dann auch eine
ähnliche, räumliche Auflösung erreicht.
Dazu braucht man dann eben ist der nächste Schritt dann interferometer zu verwenden, sogenannte Radio-Änter-Pherometer. Da gibt's dann eben auch ja zum Beispiel von von von Iram,
eben auch in den französischen Alpen Mainz, das nennt sich,
aber ein weiteres ist jetzt im Moment des Leistungsstärkes, ist Alma in Chile auf etwa 5000 Meter Höhe.
Das verwende ich halt eben auch äh für meine Arbeiten und ähm die Antennen, die sind halt eben weit genug auseinander, dass man halt dann eben eine Auflösung erreichen kann, die halt, wie gesagt, dann ähnlich ist, was man im Optischen erreichen kann.
Alma ist das Atacama Larsch millimeter Submilimeter are, also ganz viele äh kleine Teleskope, die da oben auf der Hochebene in der Atacama-Wüste äh verteilt sind und äh wo's ganz schwierig ist, da hinzukommen.
Ja genau richtig,
das Glück, ich war schon mal dort naja, wir erwarten eine Konferenz in Chile. Zweitausendelf war das glaube ich und dann gab's halt eben noch die Möglichkeit, äh dass man halt dann eben noch ähm das Ziel ist grob besuchen kann und,
sogar zweimal an dem an dem Teleskop. Dort hatten das erste Mal halt eben im Rahmen dieser Konferenz
zuerst ungefähr 3000 Meter Höhe. Da hat man dann vorher noch geguckt, ob da auch medizinisch alles alles okay ist.
Dann sind wir halt dann eben hochgefahren auf 5000 Meter Höhe und ja ich war wirklich sehr nah an den Antennen, also ich konnte es jetzt nicht berühren, aber fast so.
Sauerstoffmaske.
Also nee, oben waren wir ohne. Also man kann schon noch ähm.
Arschloch atmen.
Man kann rumlaufen, also,
aber man muss halt eben aufpassen und ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass dann einer von den Konferenzteilnehmern der hatte da ein bisschen zu kämpfen, aber es kommt halt eben im leider leider vor und das hat auch nicht unbedingt was zu tun, ob man Leistungssportler ist oder nicht
Das war halt eben die erste Gelegenheit und dann im Rahmen meiner Forschungsarbeiten bevor ich nach Wien gegangen war ich war ich in Frankreich,
und habe dann eben Beobachtungen einen Antrag gestellt, äh sogenannten Apex Teleskop. Das ist Arterkama Parsfinder-Experiment, das ist ein Teleskop, das wird,
von der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft. Ähm wie soll ich sagen, ja geleitet, geführt.
Und da habe ich halt im Antrag gestellt, da wurde eben auch akzeptiert und das äh spannend war es. Man durfte halt wirklich tatsächlich beobachten durchführen und ich habe tatsächlich auf 5000 Meter Höhe Beobachtungen durchgeführt.
Das war dann eben einige Monate später und davor mussten wir medizinische Untersuchungen machen. Ich war eben damals in Frankreich. Wir waren dann auch an so einem spezialisierten äh Institut. Da waren halt vor allem auch Bergsteiger dorten.
Bin dann auch Radel gefahren auf der Höhe von Mont Blanc,
hat alles gut geklappt. Wir hatten an unser Zertifikat und mit diesem Zertifikat und mit dieser Untersuchung, mit der Bestande untersuchen, konnten wir dann eben auch ähm zum Teleskop äh fahren.
Ich war daneben mehrere Beobachtungs ähm Tage, wir sind dann früh immer von Sankt Pedro, der Art der Saison auf 22500 Meter Höhe ist es.
Der letzte Ort, ne? So und.
Ja, genau richtig. Sind wir dann immer hochgefahren mitm mitm Fahrzeug eben von von den Kollegen,
ungefähr, wenn ich mich äh rechts entsinne, eine Stunde dauert es etwa und dann waren wir eben, dann hat man eben tagsüber beobachtet. Wir waren natürlich dann in dem Container drin und der Container hat natürlich dann auch einen Sauerstoffgehalt, so wie man das halt eben gewöhnt ist, also,
auf null oder 2000 Meter oder wie auch immer.
Aber es gab eben richtig gesagte Sauerstoffmasken und auch andere Sachen wie Schokolade oder so.
Ja zum Beispiel wie ich noch dunkel daran erinnern kann äh irgendwie Schokolade kann auch kurz ähfristig mal helfen.
Ah, okay.
Genau und was halt eben auch spannend war.
Auch nachts da oben?
Nee, nachts nicht. Also wir sind dann, haben im praktischen tagsüber beobachtet, weil das war halt eben so, mein astronomisches Objekt, das war eben nur tagsüber beobachtbar. Aber im Radiobereich kann man eben auch tagsüber
weil es halt eben keine starke Quelle gibt. Also im Optischen kann man halt deshalb bei uns nicht beobachten tagsüber, weil's halt eben die Sonne gibt. Aber wie gesagt, im Radiobereich gibt's halt,
kein Objekt, was halt äh super hell ist und deswegen kann man ja eben auch tagsüber beobachten, weil der Radiohimmel schaut halt eben ganz anders aus, eben als der der optische Himmel.
Klar. Aber wenn man aber nachts Wasser dann in Sankt Pedro, ich meine da dürfte ja immer noch ganz ordentlich Himmel zu sehen sein, also.
Ja, nee, also der Himmel ist schon.
Den Galaxien da nochmal ein bisschen näher als sonst?
Nee, also das das sind schon einzigartige Momente, wenn wenn man wirklich die Milchstraße sieht und auch wenn man Glück hat eben hängt von der Jahreszeit ab, wenn man dann eben auch die magianischen Wolken sehr toll sieht, das ist schon beeindruckend. Ich.
Bloßen Auge.
Ja ja und ich kann mich auch erinnern, wie ich dann auch bei der mit dem nein nicht, nee, es war nicht ein paar andere, es war ein
werde ich nie vergessen. Wir haben auch abends eben beobachtet und wenn man da mal, sage ich mal, seinen Rundgang gemacht hat, um frische Luft zu bekommen und,
vor allem wenn dann eben auch der Mond nicht da war, dann war's dann nochmal dunkler und wenn man da so die wie gemahlen die Milchstraße sieht, das das war schon ziemlich beeindruckend, das war schon sind schon Momente, die man einfach nicht mehr vergisst.
Und ja richtig und vielleicht nochmal zurückkommen zu den Beobachtungen halt eben. Also wir haben halt eben tagsüber beobachtet,
Ab und zu war's halt dann doch ähm musste man dann doch äh sage ich mal weit genau die Geräte, die man verwenden müssen, ja eben kälter sein als eben diese Objekte, die man beobachtet, die Objekte, die wir beobachten, haben Temperaturen von zwanzig, dreißig, 40 Kelvin.
Also minus zwei, ja, minus zweihundertdreißig, Minus.
Grad Celsius und deswegen müssen müssen halt die Instrumente, die mit dem flüssigen Helium eben gekühlt werden
alle zwei Tage so, wenn ich mich noch recht entsinne, musste das halt eben auch gewechselt werden. Da habe ich dann auch mitgeholfen und das war halt dann schon später Nachmittag, früher Abend. Da war's dann schon relativ kühl.
Werde ich nie vergessen und dann sind wir halt eben auch runtergefahren und beim Runterfahren muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, weil's da eben auch äh wilde Eseln gibt,
damit ja richtig, es sind dann natürlich auch auf der Straße und so da passiert da nichts, sondern dann sind wir da wieder runtergefahren und dann,
haben wir halt es war wirklich ein muss ich sagen beeindruckendes Erlebnis, das ich ja eben auch auf dieser Höhe halt beobachten konnte. Es war werde ich nie vergessen.
So, aber das ist ja noch nicht das ganze Instrumentarium, was äh bei dir zum Einsatz kommt. Welche anderen äh Teleskope und Methoden müssen wir denn noch ins Feld führen?
Also ich denke.
Mit den Teleskopen sind wir fast abgeschlossen, also was ist jetzt ein neues Teleskop gibt, was halt eben vorher schon erwähnt hast, weil du schon mal drüber gesprochen hast ja eben das James Webspace Telesko.
Habe ich ja eben auch äh Glück gehabt jetzt in der ersten Runde. Nennt sich das bei uns Astronomen,
Beobachtungsantrag gestellt, also in dem Falle wollte ich einen sogenannten Galaxienhaufen, der in Entstehung ist, also ich nenne Galaxienhaufen auch immer Städte von Galaxien.
Der halt eben in in Construction ist, den wollte ich ganz gerne beobachten und habe da eben ein Beobachtungsantrag gestellt zusammen mit Kollegen aus Japan,
Der wurde dann bewilligt und jetzt warte ich halt eben drauf, dass dann eben alles gut klappt und dass dann irgendwann mal äh die Daten kommen.
Wann würde dann diese Beobachtung stattfinden, wenn das jetzt so alles halbwegs nach Plan läuft?
Ja, das ist noch nicht ganz klar, also die beobachten, die sollen ja jeden soweit zum Sommer beginnen, also sie hat dann nicht nur Cycle One, sondern ist natürlich auch so die verschiedenen Teams, die die Instrumente gebaut haben für das James Webspace Teleskop.
Die werden, sage ich mal, mit Beobachtungszeit äh bezahlt. Das nennt sich Garantie Time,
die verschiedenen Wissenschaftsteam haben dann schon Beobachtungsprogramme vorgeschlagen, die dann eben auch sage ich mal äh bewilligt worden sind innerhalb des Teams und natürlich auch gecheckt worden sind, dass
durchführbar sind. Die werden dann auch äh parallel dazu beobachtet.
Und es kann also es kann sein, dass es im ersten Jahr beobachtet wird unser Projekt aber auch ein bisschen später, aber wir werden das so um den April rum erfahren, wann wir dann tatsächlich mit unseren Daten
können, weil was die auch beim Champs Web eben gemacht haben ist, also die haben ein bisschen mehr
Projekte wie soll ich sagen, also akzeptiert, als es eigentlich Beobachtungszeit im ersten Jahr gibt, aber um halt eben flexibel zu sein mit den verschiedenen Instrumenten und auch eben was was halt gerade am Himmel beobachtbar ist.
Teleskop ist ja jetzt so ein super Infrarot äh Empfänger also nochmal sehr viel kälter da draußen äh am La Grange Punkt.
Äh zwei ich glaube das eigentliche Messinstrument wird auch nur noch auf wenige Kelvin runter äh gekühlt, also es ist wirklich
kalt und wir sind in der Lage sozusagen auch noch so das letzte Photon, was wo du irgendwoher anfliegt zu äh erkennen und das ist ja auch Sinn der ganzen Sache, denn man will ja,
weit in die Vergangenheit schauen. Das ist natürlich jetzt gerade für die Galaxienentstehung das Ding, oder? Also ich meine, worauf schaust du denn,
also wie tief die Vergangenheit blickst du mit diesem Galaxienhaufen, wie weit geht das zurück? Weiß man das jetzt überhaupt schon.
Ja ja also zum Beispiel den Galaxienhaufen, den den wir beobachten, der nennt sich das sogenannte Spider-Wap äh Bruttocluster. Der der Spinnennetze Galaxienhaufen, Brutto Bruttohaufen.
Der ist ungefähr also das Licht braucht zu uns etwa 10 Milliarden Jahre.
Also wir sehen ihn sozusagen in einem Zustand, wie er vor zehn Milliarden Jahren war und ähm.
Dann kann man daraus schon Schlüsse ziehen, wann sich diese Galaxie überhaupt gebildet hat, wie alt diese Sterne da sind, also sind das sozusagen dann auch wirklich mit die ersten Sterne, die sich im Universum gebildet haben?
Ja, nicht unbedingt. Also was man halt eben, wenn man dem, also wenn man den eben beobachtet, was man eben dann eben,
man kann also wir wir messen natürlich äh sein äh die Mitglieder von diesem Galaxienhaufen,
Darüber kann man dann eben eine Idee von der von der von der Masse, von diesem Galaxienhaufen bekommt. Das ist aber dann nicht nur die stillare Masse, sondern die die ganze Masse eben auch äh zusammen mit der mit der dunklen Materie,
Und dann gibt's halt eben verschiedene Modelle.
Eben auch ähm mit bezüglich der Entwicklung von Galaxien Galaxienhaufen, dann kann man eben eine Schätzung machen, welche Masse dieser Galaxienhaufen in unserem lokalen Universum hätte. Also
zum Beispiel eine eine Masse hat, eine Größe, wie zum Beispiel der Wirgo Galaxinhaufen, den du gerade eben erwähnt hast. Aber es gibt noch einen äh ein größeres Schwergewicht. Das nennt sich äh Koma Galaxienhaufen. Der Zucker eine eine eine Sternmasse von
Sehen zu hoch. 5zehn äh Sonnenmassen.
Wie viel Galaxien hast du denn schon so ähm entdeckt? Also was er selber welche auch äh,
quasi erstmalig gefunden. Wie wie geschieht das? Ist das Zufall oder,
speziell auf die Suche und guckt sich explizit äh die schwarzen Flecken an weil es gibt ja jetzt dieses,
beeindruckende Bild äh von Hable, dieses äh Deepfield, wo man einfach mal gesagt hat, okay jetzt jetzt gucken wir mal irgendwohin, wo bisher aus unserer Sicht noch gar nichts war, so einfach so ein kleiner Patch, der einfach,
schwarz war, weil einfach alle Instrumente bisher da nichts Nennenswertes ähm haben, detektieren,
könnten und dann möglichst lange draufgehalten und da irgendwie alles äh Licht gesammelt, was sozusagen kam und dann stellen wir fest so, oh mein Gott, it's full of Galaxys, also es war sozusagen einfach,
komplett voll mit ähm Galaxien, die man so nie gesehen hat, weil man einfach noch nicht lange genug
hingeschaut. Also ist das sozusagen auch dein dein Ansatz oder wo beziehst du oder oder gehst du primär auf Galaxien, die du sowieso schon in irgendeinem Suve mal abgefallen ist, aber man muss ja sozusagen erstmal irgendwo hin orientieren. Wie wie wie gehst du da vor?
Äh es gibt verschiedene Ansätze, also zum Beispiel eben mit dem mit dem Spider-Wap ähm äh Galaxien äh Haufen.
Der wurde eben im im Optischen, na, im verroten Bereich, eben entdeckt
aber wir sind auch davon ausgegangen, dass sich sogenannte Galaxien in dem befinden können. Das sind halt eben Galaxien, die sehr stark
skurriert sind, die halt eben 99Prozent ihrer Energie halt eben imfraroten Bereich ausstrahlen und und eben eigentlich im optischen Bereich fast sogar unsichtbar sind und da haben wir.
Start-Star Dust.
Starbursts. Starburs, Starburst, ja. Der Name kommt halt eben daher, dass er Leben in einem sehr kurzen Zeitraum halt eben äh,
enorm viele Sterne entstehen, zum Beispiel eben in unserer in unserer Milchstraße geht man davon aus, dass eben eins bis fünf Sonnenmassen pro Jahr produziert werden.
Diesen Starburse geht man halt eben davon aus, dass halt eben bis zu mehreren tausend Sonnenmassen pro Jahr entstehen.
Aber ist natürlich dann eben so, wie ich dann eben das vorher auch erwähnt hatte, ist mit dem 30 Meter Teleskop, mit dem molekularen Wasserstoff, mit dem Gasreservoir, wo halt eben daraus die Sterne entstehen. Das hat praktisch eben auch das Treibstoff für die Stirne entstehen, der ist sehr nur begrenzt.
Und äh so ein Starbist dauert halt dann eben nicht eine Milliarden Jahre, sondern ist halt eben nach etwa vielleicht zehn Millionen Jahren schon vorbei.
Halt eben eine eine kurze Phase in der in der Entwicklung eben von Galaxien.
Das heißt, es entsteht die Masse. Also die Masse entsteht ja nicht, die ist ja eh schon da, aber es lumpt sich sozusagen zu Sternen zusammen.
Genau richtig richtig. Also man haltet eben den äh molekularen Wasserstoff und kollabiert halt eben und daraus entstehen halt dann eben eine neue Generation von von Sterne.
Wie wie es man sozusagen auf diese Galaxie gekommen, wenn die kaum zu sehen ist. Also hat man sie aktiv gesucht auf irgendeine Art und Weise. Also sucht man nach speziellen Patterns?
Genau, es ist dann eben eine aktive Suche. Man hat halt eben dann zum Beispiel Instrumente, die oder Teleskope auch, die halt dann im im Bereich äh zum Beispiel eben sehr sensitiv sind,
Guckt man die die Galaxien oder den Galaxienhaufen, das Objekt, was man halt eben beobachtet, halt
einfach in einen anderen Wellenlängenbereich an und in dem Fall bei diesem Galaxienhaufen hat man halt eben,
Galaxien äh gesehen im emperroten Bereich, wo man halt äh vorher nichts gesehen hatte,
Und dann gibt's halt eben Nachbeobachtungen, dann werden auch eben Datensätze von verschiedene Wellenlächen äh Bereich eben äh zusammengenommen, um halt eben die Galaxie zu sehen. Das bedeutet ja nicht, wenn man jetzt die Galaxien im verroten Bereich sieht, dass man,
was die dann nicht dem anderen Wellenbereich äh auffindbar ist, sondern man versucht halt eben die Daten miteinander zu kombinieren, um halt eben praktisch die Galaxy über verschiedenen äh Wellenbereich ähm äh zu studieren, zu charakterisieren.
Schon die ganze Zeit dieses Bild aus Blade Runner im Kopf, wo man irgendwie so äh immer durch das Foto durchgeht und dann so ja äh Computer in Hans und dann klack klack, klack, klack, klack und dann hat man das irgendwie so so funktioniert das ja nicht.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, dann guckt man sich das halt mal an. So also was ist denn das überhaupt für ein Prozess? Also die Teleskope,
Okay, den sagt man irgendwie hier, äh ihr gebt mir Zeit,
Guck doch mal da hin, das passt doch. Da schaut ihr doch sowieso gerade hin. Da seid ihr ausgerichtet. Da steht die Erde richtig et cetera. Dann,
da die Klappe aufgemacht, das Teleskop äh schaut hin und zeichnet ja erstmal alles roh auf, was da irgendwie kommt. Das Teleskop selber,
ja in keiner Form, nämlich jetzt mal an oder wird es schon in irgendeiner Form auf irgendetwas parametrisiert? Also man kriegt ja quasi so ein Rohdatenstrom von
allem, was da irgendwie rumzurbt und in irgendeiner Form in diesem entsprechenden Frequenzbereich äh Signale von sich
das wird dann irgendwie aufgezeichnet, dürfte sich wahrscheinlich um Terrawates handeln jedes Mal, weiß ich nicht. Und was passiert dann damit? Wie arbeitest du damit.
Aber was ich vielleicht davor noch erwähnen möchte ist, also bevor man ans Teleskop kommt, ist auch sehr viel Arbeit. Also man muss,
Man muss ja erstens mal eine Idee haben und dann ist es natürlich auch so, man kann jetzt nicht sagen und sagt,
zum Teleskop, ich möchte jetzt da mal beobachten, sondern da gibt's halt eben auch Competition. Äh
gibt halt eben bei den verschiedenen Teleskopen, gibt's ja dann ich sage mal eine Frist, wo man entweder zweimal pro Jahr oder bei Alma ist es einmal pro Jahr, wo man dann eben die sogenannten Beobachtungsanträge einreichen kann.
Ist man dann eben zum Beispiel der sogenannte Principle Investiga. Da gibt's dann eben auch ein Team mit den mit den sogenannten co-Eis.
Und da schreibt man dann eben einen Antrag, also da schreibt man eben meistens eine Motivation, induction über das Thema,
Dann natürlich auch, was man machen will und warum das wichtig ist.
Was wir wirklich daraus lernen, was der nächste Schritt ist eben halt eben in seinem Themengebiet, wie es zum Beispiel bei mir ist bei Galaxinenentwicklung, was man daraus lernt,
Und darüber hinaus ähm muss man denn eben auch angeben, wie viel Beobachtungszeit man eigentlich beantragt, in welchem Beobachtungsmodus wie du vorher zum Beispiel auch schon erwähnt hattest. Es gibt ja spektroskopie aber man kann zum Beispiel auch äh schöne Bilder machen.
Bilder eben an. Schöne Bilder hat man erst, nachdem man Datenreduktion gemacht hat, was du eben vorher schon erwähnt hast und das hängt halt eben von den verschiedenen Teleskopen ab. Das
ist schon sehr, kann sehr kompetitiv äh sein, also der sogenannte kann bis zu zehn sein, also die Chance ist 1 zu 10, dass du vielleicht äh dann weg.
Zehnmal, zehnmal mehr Leuten, eine Zeit wird beantragt, als tatsächlich vorhand.
Richtig beobachtungsanträge. Es gibt, wie gesagt, es hängt vom vom Teleskop ab, auch vom Instrument. Und das ist natürlich dann schon also ja.
Job sein da in der Auswahlkommission zu sein und irgendwie so vielen Leuten Absagen zu erteilen.
Richtig, er hat äh ja ich war auch schon in in solchen äh Kommissionen, was man, denke ich, auch erwähnen sollte, ist jetzt in den letzten Jahren hat sich das Q-Sederin äh gewissermaßen geändert. Es geht jetzt wirklich zu anonymes.
Ich meine, wir normalerweise als Antragsteller, wir wissen eh nicht, wer im Komitee ist. Das erfährt man dann vielleicht äh danach. Aber auch äh die Leute, die im Komitee sind.
Soll nicht wissen, wer da.
Richtig richtig es geht halt eben darum wegen dem Namen auch eben Gender-Balance und auch eben äh und auch eben sage ich mal
schon Leute, die halt jedem länger mit dabei sind, um halt wirklich das ähm so fair wie möglich halt eben zu machen, weil es gibt halt eben Statistiken und und die zeigen halt eben, dass es halt dann eben.
Die alten Männer sind, die immer die Zeit kriegen, ne.
Halt eben bei es gibt aus aus irgendwelchen Gründen und es wurde halt eben wirklich in den letzten Jahren von verschiedenen Observatoren wirklich äh sehr sehr studiert.
Und es gibt zum einen eben das mit den Komitees, wie sie zum Beispiel auch mit dem, aber was man auch äh mehr dazu tendiert ist, wird zum Beispiel auch bei Alma ähm gemacht, aber auch zum Beispiel jetzt bei den Esoteresgruppen ist.
Man reicht einen Beobachtungsantrag ein.
Und dann zum Beispiel bei Eimer verpflichtet man sich, dass man dann auch tatsächlich dann zehn Beobachtungsanträge von anderen Leuten, also von seinen Mitbewerbern, dann eben auch ähm durchschaut, eine Bewertung ab,
gegeneinander selbst bewertet,
diese Methode scheint anscheinend ganz gut zu funktionieren und das wird halt eben in in wie gesagt bei der bei Alma wird das jetzt schon schon praktiziert,
praktisch selbst,
Hotel, also natürlich nicht seinen eigenen Antrag, aber den Antrag äh von von Leuten, also ich muss jetzt nicht unbedingt das gleiche Themengebiet sein, also es kann schon ein bisschen ähnlich sein, aber ist natürlich klar.
Sowohl wenn man den Komitees als auch eben sage ich mal in diesem Prozess, wo man dann als Mitbewerber auch die Beobachtungsanträge durchschaut, wird man eben natürlich auch gefragt, ob's Konflikte gibt, dass halt
man kein bekommt, da wo der Kollege vom gleichen Institut zum Beispiel drauf ist oder zum Beispiel mit Leuten, mit denen man sehr stark zusammenarbeitet, dass man die halt eben nicht äh beurteilen soll, sondern es ist halt wirklich,
so fair es möglich halt äh sein äh soll.
Ketzerisch reinwerfen so na ja ich meine äh wenn man wenn man die ganze Konkurrenz mitbewertet dann sagt man einfach ja der Rest ist alles Quatsch äh nur meins ist toll. Das,
Wird sicherlich so nicht stattfinden, aber was ist denn quasi Sinn dieser Methode an der Stelle? Also was will man damit
bewirken, dass es mehr Awareness gibt für äh was sonst noch so kommt oder dass man Kollaborationen feststellt oder dass,
es ist einfach nur eine Arbeitsteilung und und und die Ethik ist halt einfach im Wissenschaftsbereich so, dass man äh ordentlich bewährt.
Ja zum einen also man hat gar nicht die Möglichkeit jetzt sage ich mal sein eigenes Proposil zu zu pushen, sondern man kriegt ja zum Beispiel sage ich mal zehn pro Person wie das jetzt bei Alma bei der letzten Runde war,
Und dann macht man das einfach so. Das Beste ist Nummer 1 und das Schlechteste ist Nummer zehn.
Das macht halt jeder äh Gutachter, Gutachterin so und daraus ergibt sich eine Durchschnittsbewertung.
Also man gibt sozusagen ein Ranking raus und nicht einen absoluten Wert, wie gut man das findet. Irgendwas muss immer das Beste sein sozusagen.
Ja genau. Man hat halt und jeder hat auch immer andere Zehen pro.
Das funktioniert.
Und es ist natürlich auch so, ich meine ich erwarte ja auch, dass meine Kollegen das mein.
Wollte es auch keinem unterstellen, dass es so ist. Ich habe nur gerade versucht äh zu verstehen, wie die Logik ist, aber in dem Moment, wo man sagt, okay, man stellt nur ein Ranking her, muss es ja quasi einen Gewinner äh geben und dadurch nivelliert es sich, weil da ist man dann wahrscheinlich ehrlich.
Und was man natürlich auch ähm dadurch spart, das sind zum Beispiel auch Reisekosten wenn man natürlich ein Komitee hat, ähm die treffen sich dann halt an einem Ort und das ist natürlich auch ein großer organisatorischer Aufwand und so ist es halt dann eben so.
Dass man das, sage ich mal, zu Hause am Computer macht und dann halt eben die Bewertung einreicht,
Man muss natürlich auch eine eine Begründung drin haben, aber es reicht nicht, wenn man jetzt sagt Nummer eins und Nummer zehn, sondern man will auch selber, wenn man den Antrag stellt, möchte man ja auch äh Feedback bekommen, was auch sinnvoll ist. Wo man wirklich beim nächsten Mal, wenn es dieses Mal das nicht klappt.
Beim nächsten Mal eine Chance hat, dass es halt dann eben akzeptiert wird.
Okay, das heißt, man erhält als Bewerber auch die Bewertung oder die Begründung für das Ranking von den anderen zurück, um das selber studieren zu können, aber man sieht dann nicht, von wem es ist.
Ne. Möchte ich auch gar nicht wissen.
Okay, gut verstanden zu haben. Alles klar. Also es ist ein komplexer äh Prozess. Es ist ein offener Wettbewerb.
Um die Zeit, die die Teleskope halt bieten und wenn man dann gewonnen hat, so, dann.
Vorhin schon bei James Web Teleskop, dann wird das halt irgendwann terminiert. Das äh hängt dann
sehr viel davon äh ab, was sonst noch so äh beobachtet wird, dass man das eben gut miteinander kombinieren kann und dann kann das irgendwie Monate in der Zukunft liegen,
Wenn es so jedes Jahr festgelegt wird, kann's auch ein Jahr dauern, bis man dann sozusagen seine Beobachtungszeit bekommt.
Und dann gibt's halt eben auch zwei Möglichkeiten. Also eine Möglichkeit ist halt eben, dass man praktisch vor Ort beobachtet,
Also zum Beispiel jetzt bei den bei unserem Teleskopen hier, aber auch zum Beispiel bei der ESO, dass man halt eben vor Ort fliegt.
Oder was halt eben auch seit einigen Jahren stark verbreitet ist, ist halt eben der sogenannte Service-Mode.
Das bedeutet, dass man halt eben sein Beobachtungsprogramm einreicht mit den Parametern, wie man das halt eben beobachten will
dann wird es halt eben von Mitarbeitern wie jetzt zum Beispiel bei unserem Teleskop,
führt die Beobachtung. Man gibt halt eben auch ähm Instruktionen an, wie das halt eben gemacht werden muss. Und wie gesagt, es werden dann eben auch Parameter wie zum Beispiel Beobachtungszeit oder welchen Filter man,
möchte oder welche natürlich die Position der Galaxien, die man beobachten will, wird halt eben angegeben und dann wird das halt eben durchgeführt. Und der Vorteil von diesem Service-Mode ist natürlich so
dass ähm das jederzeit beobachtet werden äh kann. Also die wird halt eben geguckt, was waren die Bedingungen, ähm die man nachgefragt hat, die Wetterbedingungen, waren das jetzt sehr gute oder eher schlechtere. Wenn man jetzt natürlich wisset Herr Mode ähm einreicht
besteht halt das Risiko, wenn man dann vor Ort ist am Teleskop und dann ist drei Nächte schlechtes Wetter, dass man halt dann keine Daten bekommt und da muss man halt den Antrag wiederstellen. Aber es gibt natürlich auch gewisse Projekte, wo es halt einfach erforderlich ist, dass man wirklich vor vor Ort ist.
Dass man gleich die Daten inspiziert und dann Entscheidungen trifft. Zum Beispiel das war auch beim 30 Meter Teleskop so. Wir hatten Galaxien beobachtet, wo wir eben nicht wussten, was die Entfernung der Galaxien ist.
Wir wollten halt eben eine Emissionslinie finden und das reicht ja nicht nur eine Linie, wenn man eine Linie hat, weiß man immer noch nicht, die Rotverschiebung, sondern man braucht verschiedene Linien, um.
Eine Emissionslinie um um die Distanz dann äh daraus.
Genau richtig, genau richtig. Also das nennt sich ja spektroskopische Rotverschiebung, also nur mit einer Spektroskopischen Rotverschiebung weiß man ja wirklich die genaue Entfernung der Galaxie und deswegen braucht man halt eben mindestens zwei emissions.
Man schaut hin und man sieht dann eigentlich so, ich äh vermute mal die die typischen Muster der äh das, was man sozusagen erwartet, nur eben mit einer entsprechenden Verschiebung und der Verschiebung kann man dann die Distanz entnehmen.
Ja genau richtig und zum Beispiel mit dem 30 Meter Teleskop ist halt das Gute, man nimmt die Daten auf,
Dann kann man die auch gleich reduzieren, also erstmal, sage ich mal, vorläufig, aber dann kann man schon gucken, ob da was ist oder nicht. Und wenn man zum Beispiel eine Linie hat
kann man sein Gerät so tunen, dass man dann eben beim anderen Frequenzbereich guckt, um halt eben die zweite Linie zu finden, die da vorhergesagt ist.
Das ist halt eben der Vorteil, wenn man halt direkt eben am am Teleskop ist und,
Genau, also das sind dann sage ich mal die die beiden ähm Methoden und abhängig auch äh also Visiter Mode und Service-Mode und abhängig auch vom Teleskop.
Beim da hat man dann schon mit dem Beobachtungsantrag eben auch schon die Beobachtungsmodi eingereicht. Es gab dann zwar nach der nachdem das akzeptiert worden ist, nochmal die Möglichkeit
drauf, einen Blick zu werfen, die Kollegen vom haben dann auch Sachen gefunden, die man vielleicht verbessern kann, aber in der Regel ist es das, was man beantragt hat und vor allem man kann nicht sagen, uh, ich habe jetzt einen Fehler in der Berechnung gemacht, ich möchte.
Ich jetzt fünf Stunden oder so, das geht natürlich nicht. Es gibt auch eben dann die Möglichkeit oder nicht die Möglichkeit oder es wird so gemacht.
Nachdem der Antrag akzeptiert worden ist,
dann erst einreicht, wie man das tatsächlich also die Beobachtungsparameter. Man hat das natürlich schon im beschrieben, aber es wird dann eben halt
alles genau angegeben Integrationszeit, welchen Filter man benutzt, Koordinaten und so weiter. Das nennt sich auch sogenannte Phase zwei und das ist dann auch schon schon harte Arbeit, wo man auch äh Fehler machen könnte und deswegen muss man da auch
genau arbeiten, aber das ist auch schon, wenn man den Beobachtungsantrag stellt, wie ich schon gesagt habe, wenn man jetzt einen Fehler in der Kalkulation macht, ist das halt dann nicht so optimal.
Und dann, jetzt komme ich da endlich zurück zu deiner Frage eigentlich, was man da macht,
entweder man ist vor Ort vom Teleskop, dann kriegt man gleich die Daten oder die Daten werden für einen genommen und wenn dann die Daten eben die Qualität hat, die man eben beantragt,
also den sogenannten Noise zum Beispiel jetzt im im Radiobereich, wenn dann der erreicht worden ist, dann bekommt man halt eben die Daten.
Quasi eine Eigenschaft, die man der Beobachtung ansehen kann, wie viel äh Störgeräusche da drin sind.
Genau richtig, also es gibt halt eben dann äh von den Mitarbeitern, von den verschiedenen Observatoren die schauen sich da mal schon schnell die Daten an, wo halt eben das erreicht worden ist, was halt wir eben beantragt hatten und dann bekommt man die Daten.
Woher wisst ihr denn das? Also woher wissen die denn, dass das von den Signalen, die man bekommen hat so und so viel.
Na, es wird halt eben gemessen, also.
Wie kann man denn die Noise messen, also woher weiß man, dass das Signal, dass das Signal ist und nicht neu ist, also wo wodurch wird die Noise dann erzeugt.
Der Noise, der Noise ist äh sogenannte das Rauschen, also wie soll ich sagen, die die.
Ja, aber wie lässt sich die also wo du wodurch fluktuiert die? Ist das nicht eine Eigenschaft, einfach das Testoskops? Wie gut, dass Teleskop so misst.
Hat was mit dem Teleskop im Instrument natürlich zu tun, aber es hat natürlich auch was mit der Beobachtungs äh Methode äh zu tun. Man hat
beobachtet zum Beispiel jetzt seine Galaxie mit der Emissionslinie
dann sage ich mal links und rechts von der äh von der ist ja gar nichts, weil da eben keine Emissionslinie ist. Es gibt so Parameter, die nennt sich Signal to Noise.
Fünf,
Also das halt eben das Signal im Vergleich zum Rauschen, was man müssten. Faktor fünf äh ähm eben gut ist und das sind. Das hat eben auch was mit Statistik dann zu tun. Da geht man davon aus, dass das dann eine sehr hohe signifikant eben dieser Messung ist.
So wird das eben gemacht, also.
Okay, also das ist dann sozusagen noch mal so eine Hürde, die übersprungen werden,
muss und im Idealfall ist jetzt alles super gelaufen und äh die Beobachtung hat so stattgefunden, wie man das äh möchte beziehungsweise in diesem Modus dann halt auch so interaktiv, dass man sagt okay, alles klar. Jetzt haben wir müssen wir erstmal den Abstand,
bestimmen, weil das dann für die künftigen Messungen eine andere Einstellung des Teleskops erfordert, ne? Und dann erhält man die Daten.
Sofort danach dauert das noch äh Tage, Wochen, Monat.
Halt eben auch äh von dem Observatorium drauf an und wie auch äh intensiv äh die Datenkontrolle ist, zum Beispiel bei Alma
ihm wirklich ähm ja sicherstellen, dass wir als dann Benutzer eben auch wirklich die Daten bekommen, die wir halt eben gefordert haben. Aber es kann ja was sein, dass bei den Beobachtungen was schief gegangen ist oder so.
Dass dann vielleicht die Wetterbedingungen äh sich äh kurzzeitig geändert haben. Das kann auch im Optischen zum Beispiel sein. Wenn du sagst, ich möchte ein haben von besser als einer Bogensekunde.
Aber auch die Astronomen sind ja keine Vorhersage. Es kann ja dann sein, dass ich dann plötzlich das Siegen von 1 auf 1,5 verschlechtert und das hat natürlich starke Auswirkungen wiederum auf auf den auf das sogenannte Rauschen. Das wird halt dann eben eben.
Verschlechterung zum Beispiel durch die Atmosphäre, die man sozusagen nicht unter Kontrolle hat. Vulkanausbruch, was.
Richtig genau. Genau, also es hat nichts mit der Galaxy selber zu tun, sondern das hat äh praktisch zwischen uns zu tun, richtig mit mit der mit der Atmosphäre richtig. Wenn man halt eben vom vom Boden beobachtet.
Wie kriegt man denn die Daten dann?
Ähm äh wie man die Daten bekommt.
Per Mail.
Also früher war das tatsächlich so. Früher hat man ähm sich auch die Daten nur zuschicken lassen. Hat man die ja dann zum Beispiel äh von der äh von der mit der CD bekommen.
Mittlerweile schickt man sich die Daten, äh kann man die Daten runterladen, zum Beispiel es gibt dann dann eben FTB Server, da werden die Daten dann hinterlegt und selber lädt man dann die Daten einfach runter.
Und wie gesagt äh von von Teleskop zu Teleskop kann das halt eben relativ äh zügig sein, aber auch um noch ein, zwei, drei, vier Monate äh warten, aber es kann natürlich auch so sein, dass zum Beispiel eine Galaxy, sage ich mal, im im Januar beobachtet wird, aber halt
nicht die ganze Zeit, sondern da wird dann auch
im Februar und dann bekommt man natürlich nicht die Daten schon im Januar, sondern im Februar. Es hängt natürlich dann auch wieder vom Projekt, da wenn man sagt, wenn man mit 50 Prozent der Daten auch schon was machen kann
dann kann man vielleicht auch mal nachfragen, ob man vielleicht äh vorher Zugriff hat. Aber wie gesagt, das hängt halt wirklich stark von den von den Observatoren ab und auch von ihren Regolarien.
Wie einheitlich sind denn diese Datenformate? Kriegt man immer alles im selben Format von allen Teleskopen oder man da hält ja der Teufel im im Detail, ne? Da kann ja jedes Bit äh.
Einen Unterschied machen, wenn man mit den Daten was anfangen will.
Also was ich halt.
Eingebürgert hat, ist das sogenannte Schutzformat. Und das hat einen sogenannten Header, da stehen halt dann eben Informationen äh zu dem Fall dort und wie Beobachtungszeit, wer beobachtet hat.
Koordinaten und dann äh im zweiten Teil, das sind halt dann praktisch wirklich die Daten entweder ein Bild oder ein Spektrum.
Image Transportsystem von der.
Ja genau, das wollte ich vorher grad sagen, da gibt's eine Abkürzung.
Mhm ja 1achtzig entwickelt, alles klar.
Genau richtig, aber bei bei gewissen Teleskopen gibt's auch ein anderes Format, aber die Observatoren sorgen dann eben dafür auch, dass es dann eben eine Software dazu gibt, dass man, wenn das Format ein wenig anders ist, dass man dann eben trotzdem mit den Daten arbeiten.
Mhm. Okay, also es ist im Prinzip so ein Datenformat, in dem man einfach so mehr dimensionelle äh Eras von von Daten und,
dann halt Spektren et cetera abbilden äh kann als Bilder, sodass halt einfach klar ist, okay er ist da dieser Bereich, den wir uns dieses Jahr angeschaut haben,
ist so dargestellt. Koordinaten sind mit drin und dann kann man das äh gleich auch einspeisen in seine eigene Verarbeitung.
Richtig, also man kann entweder das Verarbeitungstool von dem Teleskop verwenden oder,
Man verwendet auch seine eigene Verarbeitungstool. Das hängt da wirklich äh stark von den Teleskopen und auch sogar von Wellenlängenbereich ab. Zum Beispiel mit allem ist es halt so, da gibt's halt dann
mittlerweile ein Tool, wo auch
die Idee dahinter ist, das das nennt sich Casa, das ist aber nicht nur für Alma verwendet werden kann, sondern zum Beispiel auch für das Very Lager, das ist das Radioteleskop, was in dem Film mit da war, Contact.
Mhm.
Genau richtig und da versucht man zum Beispiel auch in der Radio-Astromie jetzt so ein einheitliches äh Tool zu haben, weil zum Beispiel optischen Astronomie haben wir sehr viel auch IRAF benutzt. Das konnte dann eben für verschiedene,
Aufgrund des Fitzformats eben halt hat man halt eben dann von verschiedenen Teleskopen, sage ich mal, eh so kack, wie auch immer oder auch von hier hat man da eben damit arbeiten können.
Und richtig und dann ist halt eben kommt halt eben wie gesagt
wieder eben vom Teleskop drauf an, kommt daneben ein möglicherweise harter Schritt oder oder viel Arbeit eben die Reduktion der Daten,
auch die Kalibration die Daten. Also man will ja dann eben auch wissen wie viel also man will ja die Energie zum Beispiel messen von den Galaxien oder von den Linien und dazu ist es halt eben äh fundamental, dass man eben die Daten richtig kalibriert.
Und nach der Kalibration der Daten ähm erfolgt dann eben auch,
dann die Messung zum Beispiel der der Emissionslinie, aber wenn du jetzt ein ein Bild hast eben die sogenannte Magnethode, also die die Helligkeit der Galaxie.
Und dann der nächste Schritt ist natürlich dann mit diesen Daten ähm die man dann eben reduziert hat. Kalibriert hat, dass man dann eben Analysen macht.
Eigentlich dann die wissenschaftliche Arbeit und das ist halt finde ich auch das Spannende bei einem Job. Ich mache halt nicht nur eine Sache, sondern ich habe wirklich verschiedene Tätigkeiten durchzuführen.
Vom Antrag schreiben, wo man halt wirklich seine eigene Idee hat, wo man sich auch, sage ich mal, verwirklichen kann.
Bis halt eben dann die wissenschaftliche Analyse. Und dann war's halt eben zum Schluss kommt es, das ist ja das, was bei uns ja eigentlich nur zählt. Ich vergleiche das immer ganz gern mit Fußball. Ist das Paper?
Wenn du dann deine Arbeit nicht veröffentlicht hast, dann existiert die praktisch nicht. Also das Paper ist das, wo das zeigt, du hast was gemacht und und.
Ist ein Ergebnissport, möchtest du sagen.
Ja richtig, das sage ich auch immer wieder zu meinen äh Studenten und auch äh zu meinen äh Mitarbeitern, dass.
Natürlich ein bisschen vielleicht hart an, aber im Endeffekt zählt nur das Paper.
Also du kannst noch äh so schön und das so toll gemacht haben und Trumpf gefaltet ist, aber wenn du nicht dein Paper hast oder vor allem, was halt eben auch stark zähle, ich gehe jetzt wieder im Vergleich zum Fußball, das ist das erste Auto, Paper.
Das soll wirklich auch der führende Autor von dem von dem Fußball genauso. Die größten Stars im Fußball sind nicht die Torhüter oder die Abwehrspieler, sondern sind die Stürmer. Weil die, wie du ja vorher gesagt hast, das Ergebnis praktisch.
Erstellt haben und äh dazu halt geführt haben ist. Also es ist natürlich ein ganzes Team wichtig,
Aber richtig, man wird halt dann oft gemessen oder karieren hängen halt eben auch stark davon ab, wie wie viel man publiziert hat und und auch,
Erstauto PayPal, auch vor allem auch Rosta Impact war. Also wie oft das Paper dann von den Kollegen im im Fachbereich dann auch zitiert worden ist.
Aber so kann man praktisch ein das ja wie soll ich sagen abschließen, also vom Beobachtungsantrag, also im Idealfall, akzeptiert und bist dann halt das fertiggeschriebene Paper.
Das kann schon eine Zeitspanne von eins zwei oder drei, vier Jahren sein, also eine Doktorarbeit dauert ja auch in der Regel drei, vier Jahre.
Jetzt müssen wir wieder zurückkommen zu den zum eigentlichen Ziel, nämlich die Beobachtung der Galaxien. Was was schaut man sich jetzt sozusagen äh primär,
an, was ist so der Fokus deiner Beobachtung, also was genau
schaut man sich dann an. Meiner Meinung hat so viel Daten. Das sind ja unglaubliche Datenmengen, das ja schon angedeutet, so die Reduktion ist letztlich äh entscheidend. Man man will halt ja irgendwie auf die Essenz kommen.
Was sind sozusagen die die Mysterien, die die jetzt gelöst werden sollen?
Sprechen wir mal wieder von dem Galaxienhaufen, wo halt eben die Galaxien sind, den den Galaxienhaufen, Galaxy-Protocluster ist, also,
wie gesagt äh den Haufen, also die ganze Strukturen dann eben halt eben die die Mitglieder und von diesen Mitgliedern zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt auch mit einem australianischen ähm Interfernometer, das nennt sich,
der Australian Teles
haben wir eben auch eine eine Durchmusterung von dem ganzen Galaxienhaufen eben mit Carbomonoxid in der in der in der den Übergang eins nach null äh durchgeführt und wir wollten halt rausfinden, wie viel molekular Gas ähm
jeder von diesen Galaxienhaufen äh Mitgliedern hat und vor allem äh diese Kennzahl, das ist ja praktisch der Treibstock, das ist was zur Verfügung steht,
Aber das sagt er nichts, äh ob dann die Galaxy tatsächlich alles äh wie soll ich sagen, verwendet, um Sterne zu entstehen. Und da gibt's halt eben einen weiteren Parameter, den kann man eben zum Beispiel eben auch äh mit Radioteleskopen äh beobachten, das ist halt eben der,
die wir vorher schon erwähnt hatten ist und der,
der ist auch ein Indikator, die Sternenanstörungsrate. Also man kann sich das ja auch äh sage ich mal äh vorstellen mit mit der mit der realen Welt zum Beispiel. Äh wenn Sterne entstehen, dann gibt's das Abfallprodukt der Staub.
Ist ja wie beim Hausbau oder beim Hochhausbau, du hast dann auch äh an der Baustelle eben auch Staub und dann auch mit der Messung vom Staub,
du dann eben was über die sogenannte Sternenstörungsrate sagen. Also.
Mit Staub meint man im Prinzip eine Ansammlung von allen möglichen äh Elementen, die in kleinen und größeren Mengen wild durcheinander gemischt äh existieren.
Erstmal noch nicht genug größeren Verbund drinstecken.
Richtig solide Partikel, aber die sind jetzt nicht so groß wie der Hausstaub bei uns zu Hause.
Auf atomarer Ebene.
Ja Mikrometerbereich sind die groß. Richtig und bei dem Staub ist es zum Beispiel auch eben so,
werden dann von den neugeborenen Stern, der sehr heiß ist, kann ein O-Stern zum Beispiel sein, die werden dann eben angestrahlt,
und die erhitzen sich, das ist genauso wie wir. Wir sind jetzt auch in Teneriffa mit der Sonne, um uns jetzt auch wärmer. Wir strahlen jetzt auch grad Infrarotstrahlung ab. Und das Gleiche passiert eben auch mit diesem Staubpartikel. Das wird erhitzt von der von der Strahlung von dem jungen neuen Stern,
und strahlt dann wieder ab und diese re-emitierte Energie beobachten wir dann halt eben äh im im und das Tolle ist halt eben, selbst wenn der Stern obskuriert ist durch den Staub
die man im Optischen nicht sieht, kann man praktisch doch nachweisen, da ist Sternenstehung.
Staubleuchte.
Staub eben äh beobachten. Deswegen ist es halt eben komplementär in verschiedenen Wellenlängen äh Bereichen zu beobachten.
Galaxien, die du im Optischen, das siehst du, sage ich mal, die linke Seite,
aber die rechte Seite siehst du nur ähm im infraroten Bereich, weil die rechte Seite halt eben obskuriert ist, weil da eben grad eine Verschmelzung stattfindet
genau richtig. Und dann, wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt in diesem Fall die beiden Parameter hat, das Molekulargasreservoir, aber auch die Sternumstehungsrate, kann man diese beiden äh Parameter miteinander kombinieren?
Dann eben zu sagen wie effizient in dieser Galaxie Sterne entstehen. Ob das jetzt schnell passiert oder langsam,
ob das Gasreservoir eben auch lange äh da ist oder sich schnell verbraucht, wie ich vorher eben auch schon gesagt habe, vielleicht in zehn Millionen Jahren.
Dann kam er eben auch über den Tipus von der Galaxie was sagen, also zum Beispiel unsere unsere Milchstraße oder Spiralgalaxien.
Die würden das Gas oder verbrauchen das Gas über über Gigajahre, also da geht es nicht äh rucki zucki in in zehn Millionen Jahre und wenn man jetzt dann auch im im weit entfernten Galaxienhaufen Galaxien entdeckt, die eine ähnliche
Äh Sternenstehungsraten Effizienz haben, äh wie unsere äh Milchstraße, dann dann kann man auch Galaxien vielleicht entdecken, die sich eigentlich schon wie unsere Milchstraße
benehmen, aber im weit entfernten Universum sind,
Wie hier auch schon vorher gesagt habe, ist, diese Phase ist es sehr kurz, äh wo halt eben der Starbörs stattfindet. Sprich einen großen Teil seiner Zeit äh befindet sich die Galaxie halt eben in einem Bereich, wo haltungsrate ähnlich ist.
Bei uns in der Milchstraße ist und das ist ja auch ein Unterschied mit elektrischen Galaxien. Da findet gar keine Sternungsstörungen mehr statt.
Zum Beispiel in optischen Bildung, wie ich vorher schon gesagt habe, erlebte Galaxien sind eher rot,
alte Sterne und in in in Spiralgalaxien sieht man halt eben zwar auch den zentralen Bereich, den den Ball
ähnlich zu der lipischen Galaxy, aber außen drum und rum gibt's halt eben die Spiralarme, wo man halt eben blaue Regionen sieht, äh wo halt eben Sterne entstehen.
Wenn du jetzt nach unserem Gespräch dir nochmal Fotos anschaust von Spiralgalaxien, wirst du sehen, dass du nicht nur den blauen äh bläulichen Arm siehst, sondern dass da auch so Staubwolken siehst drum rum, also die halt eben im Optischen halt eben das Licht,
gelassen haben und da sieht man halt eben dann schon die Verbindung zwischen wir da entstehen neue Sterne, aber da hast du natürlich auch Staub.
Man diese Farben, bei dieser äh äh Bilder mein Verständnis ist, die sind ja sozusagen
muss sich das glaube ich nicht so vorstellen, dass man jetzt durch einen super Teleskop durchschaut und dann sieht man genau diese Farben. Sondern das sind ja das sind quasi aus verschiedensten,
Beobachtungsfrequenzbereichen, die ja weit über unseren sichtbaren äh oder vom vom durch den Menschen im im sichtbaren Bereich ähm,
dir in irgendeiner Form Farben zugeordnet,
damit wir uns das vorstellen können, ja? Aber wenn man eine Infrarotbeobachtung macht, okay gut, wenn's nur die Ferne ist, dann kann man's halt einfach in den sichtbaren Bereich verschieben, aber die Galaxien strahlen ja in allen erdenklichen Frequenzen.
Kann man denn dann diese Bilder interpretieren, wenn du jetzt sagst, da ist ja blau, das muss ja gleich auffallen, aber ist ja jetzt nicht, ist das jetzt sozusagen nur sichtbares Licht in dem Moment, was dort abgebildet ist
oder sehe ich jetzt hier auch ein Bild von äh aus dem aus dem Radiobereich äh was mir in ein sichtbares Bild umgesetzt wird.
Genau, also das hängt halt eben äh davon ab, was man halt eben zeigt. Also wenn man jetzt im Optischen, einfach roten Bereich beobachtet, versucht man dann doch,
Farbpalette mit blau, rot, grün und so, das halt doch äh abzubilden, wie das halt tatsächlich ist, dass man einen blauen Filter verwendet hat oder zum Beispiel einen roten Filter.
Und aber halt,
richtig, aber natürlich beim Radiobereich, man sieht das ja nicht mit unserem Auge. Da hängt es dann natürlich, sage ich mal, vom vom vom Beobachter oder vomjenigen, der die Bilder dann bearbeitet ab, wie er das macht, ob sie das jetzt rot oder grün oder gelb oder äh oder violett macht,
das wird muss man halt dann natürlich auch in den Publikationen wird das dann auch natürlich angegeben, dass man sagt, man sieht da zum Beispiel in rot den molekularen Wasserstoff und in in blau sieht man jetzt zum Beispiel die die Sterne.
Und in in gelb sieht man äh den Staub. Also man
man fängt auch an sage ich mal, seine eigene Farbcodierung zu machen, aber wie gesagt, das passiert vor allem, wenn man halt eben ähm Strahlungen nimmt, wo wo das Auge eigentlich nicht sensitiv ist, wo man eben nicht sagen kann, das ist rot, blau, grün, gelb und so weiter.
Ja, deswegen hätte ich jetzt so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten äh sozusagen das zu machen, aber du hast jetzt gerade wirklich von einem Abbild im sichtbaren Bereich gesprochen, dass das also tatsächlich so wäre.
Ja, also wenn es möglich ist, dann versucht man das so zu machen. Also wenn man jetzt eben
zum Beispiel was man ja auch oft sieht ist es gibt eben auch Aufnahmen von Galaxien wo man dann auch rote Bereiche sieht, sogenannte Sternungsstehungsregionen, das wurde damit der sogenannten,
Alpha-Linie gemacht, das ist eine Kombinationslinie vom vom Wasserstoff halt eben. Bei 6.563 Angsttrümen, das ist halt eben auch dann auch eher im im äh rötlicheren Wellenlängenbereich von von uns.
Muss man unter einer Rekobinationslinie, was wird da rekombiniert?
Also das Elektron ähm wie du beweist, die spielen auf verschiedenen also so stellt man sich das vor. Auf verschiedenen Bahnen rum und es springt halt eben von einer höheren Bahn zu einer niedrigen Bahn und dadurch entsteht dann die Emissionslinie.
Messbare Energie.
Genau richtig. Und wenn das praktisch von unten nach oben springt, in diesem Schalenmodell ist es praktisch die Absorptionslinie. Es absorbiert Energie und deswegen geht es auf ein höheres Energielevel.
Kombinationslinie ist dann die.
Das ist praktisch von von einer höheren Schale auf eine auf einen höheren Energielevel äh auf ein niedrigeres Energielevel.
Okay.
Jetzt ist ja äh die Beobachtung also gerade unsere eigenen ähm okay mit unserer eigenen Galaxie mit der Milchstraße, hast es jetzt nicht so.
Wie ich's richtig verstanden habe. Ist nicht so interessant.
So würde ich das nicht sagen, aber ich fand, ich habe mich halt einfach ja weiß nicht, weit entfernt in Galaxien, haben mich halt einfach äh.
Interessiert. Ja okay, aber wissen wir jetzt schon mehr über andere Galaxien, äh weil wir die irgendwie besser beobachten können als wir unsere eigene?
Anders würde ich mal sagen. Also klar, unsere Galaxie kann man natürlich ähm im Detail studieren, aber,
zum Beispiel, was ja nicht möglich, also wie ich ja vorher schon erwähnt hatte, wir können ja wirklich nicht.
Von oben drauf schauen.
Genau richtig zum Beispiel und klar kann man sich das vorstellen wie die ungefähr ausschaut und ich denke, dass
doch ziemlich gut, aber in diesem Fall, ich kann da wirklich Galaxien beobachten, wie die halt von außen schauen, aber es hängt natürlich auch wieder ab, wie die Galaxy zu uns steht, also zum Beispiel es gibt Steibengalaxien, wo man einfach nur wo die Scheibe direkt
äh wo wir die ganze Scheibe sehen oder wenn das halt eben der Winkel anders ist, dass man halt einfach nur die äh wie soll ich sagen.
Den Rand sieht, ja.
Ja, genau richtig. Also zum Beispiel bei dieser Sombrero Galaxie ist das ja so.
Genau und man hat's natürlich jetzt auch schön äh gesehen bei der
Visualisierung des äh schwarzen Lochs durch das Event Horizon Teleskop, da war's halt auch möglich mal ein schwarzes Loch in der Ferne äh zu beobachten, während wir da so Schwierigkeiten haben in der Milchstraße, ähnliche Ergebnisse zu erzielen, auch wenn es glaube ich das Ziel des äh Projektes ist, da äh irgendwie auch noch voranzukommen.
M 87 und das ist eine elektrische Galaxie.
Wenn man jetzt sozusagen an den ähm,
an den Beginn des Universums zurückschaut. Und wir haben ja eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, ähm wann alles irgendwie begonnen hat. Oder zumindest haben wir
einen Zeitpunkt von von dem aus wir äh ausrechnen können, ohne genau zu wissen was vorher war
Ist auch erstmal egal so. Aber das Universum ist irgendwie sichtbar geworden. Galaxien, Sterne und Galaxien sind äh entstanden,
Ähm wenn man jetzt sozusagen so weit zurückschaut, wie wir bisher,
zurückschauen können, ist ja klar. James Web wird jetzt demnächst vermutlich die Karten da neu mischen, aber äh ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man jetzt noch gar nix gesehen hätte. Was kann man diesen,
Frühesten Galaxien, die man bisher hat, analysieren können, was man da sehen kann. Was kann man denen ansehen, inwiefern die,
anders einfacher sind, also womit fängt es quasi an? Also ab wann ist es überhaupt erst mal äh etwas, dass man eine Galaxie,
nennen kann und wie,
entwickeln die sich weiter? Ist es dann wirklich primär nur die Verschmelzung mit den äh anderen oder äh entwickeln sich diese Galaxien auch aus sich heraus in irgendeiner Form, ohne dass sie gleich mit anderen zusammenstoßen müssen.
Also jetzt äh bevor also die ersten Galaxien, die man halt kennt oder die man entdeckt hat, ist, da geht man davon aus, dass es ungefähr, ja,
400 Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall halt eben ist und die meisten, die sind halt
sage ich mal relativ klein, also klein als die Galaxien, die wir jetzt kennen oder auch im im späteren Universum dann beobachtet haben es, also wie gesagt, es gibt
eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die dann kleineren Galaxien miteinander sich verschmelzen, größere Bilder, aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Galaxien, die sich halt dann einfach weiterbilden, aber es hängt halt eben davon ab,
Gas vorhanden ist, äh wie ich vorher erwähnt habe, bis in der Umgebung, weil wenn das ganze Gas schon verbraucht worden ist, dann kann man ja keine neuen Sterne mehr entstehen, dann bleibt die Galaxy einfach nur, hat
alte Sterne, die kann natürlich weiterhin, weil die Sterne die die gehen da nicht einfach weg. Die bilden
Zum Beispiel weißer Zwergweite hängt dann eben von der Größe vorne von den Sternen ab, wie die sich halt eben weiterbilden, aber zum Beispiel so eine so eine Galaxie. Kann sein, dass eine Galaxy einfach
als als halt einfach weit ist. Also es gibt auch schon im im frühen Universum Galaxien, die halt eben schon.
Eigenschaften haben wie äleptische Galaxien, die jetzt nicht eine Elektrizität haben, aber die haben keine Sternentörung mehr. Ja die Sternentörung ist schon vorbei, also es kann schon noch sein, dass durch.
Weitere Prozesse halt eben durch Aggression von neuem Gas oder halt dann eben Verschmelzungen mit anderen Galaxien dann eben das wieder angeregt wird dass halt dann eben wieder sich die Galaxie transformiert oder neu Galaxie entsteht. Das muss ja auch nicht sein.
Dass sich die Galaxy ändert. Wenn die zusammenstößt, das reicht auch schon, wenn die Galaxien einfach äh sage ich mal vorbeihuschen und so. Da gibt's ja auch schon die die Gravitationskräfte oder die Gezeitenkräfte, die können auch schon dafür sorgen, dass die Galaxien dann verbogen werden oder,
Zum Beispiel, wenn man dann halt eben auch ein Galaxinhaufen ist, ist es natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit viel größer, dass sich eine Galaxie verändert, also sowohl wo sie sich halt auch befindet, aber auch eben die Form.
Dass sie dann zum Beispiel auch äh viel schneller das Gas verbraucht und die Wahrscheinlichkeit vom Zusammenstößen ist halt wesentlich äh größer und das,
halt eben auch bezüglich Galaxienentwicklung ist, in in Galaxienhaufen, die sind halt eben in in im lokalen Universum halt eben von elektrischen Galaxien dominiert,
Und deswegen ist es halt eben spannend, die sogenannten Vorgänger. Das hatte ich eigentlich gar nicht erwähnt. Äh Vorgänger von elektrischen Galaxien geht man davon aus
Ja, ein bisschen habe ich erwähnt, sind die Starpirs Galaxie, weil das sind halt eben die Verschmelzungen von zwei Scheibengalaxien und danach bildet sich eine elektrische Galaxie.
Deswegen halt dann auch zum Beispiel unser Projekt sucht man dann eben halt mit Teleskopen, die sehr sensitiv sind für Stapesaktivitivs, die Vorgänger von diesen elektrischen Galaxien und dadurch kann man dann eben auch verstehen, wie sich zum Beispiel Galaxienhaufen bilden.
Halt eben die Vorgänger von Galaxien zu finden.
Die Starbirs, aber wie gesagt durch Zusammenstöße oder einfach weil die in diesem Galaxienhaufen sind, weil's dann auch vielleicht kein Gas mehr gibt, entwickeln die sich weiter. Es gibt halt eben äh verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Was ist denn deine Lieblings äh Galaxi?
Also gibt ja ein paar coole, oder? Die man so besonders ins Herz geschlossen hat, die irgendwie Eigenschaften äh aufweisen.
Also diese äh Galaxien zum Beispiel, wie du erwähnt hast, so finde ich irgendwie in der Optik extrem beeindruckend, weil man dann einfach wirklich so einen Ring,
in dem in der Mitte irgendwie noch was äh äh sich abspielt, sieht ja so total anders aus als jetzt so eine herkömmliche herkömmliche Spiralgalaxie ist ja langweilig.
Magst ja alle, alles.
Ja aber also zum Beispiel ist so ein Galaxy, die finde ich ähm,
ziemlich cool, aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch Galaxien, die haben Ring oder ist eine andere durchgeschossen. Ich finde halt einfach auch, wie gesagt, ähm Galaxien, die miteinander sind, zu verschmelzen und die miteinander kollidieren, finde ich halt einfach
die schauen halt einfach ziemlich cool aus. Ja und zum Beispiel was ich auch ziemlich spektakulär finde ist natürlich
Galaxien, ähm die halt eben gelenzt sind, wo halt eben die Hintergrundgalaxie von der Vordergrundgalaxie auf Vordergrundhaufen das Licht stark äh verkrümmt ist und schaut halt eben äh ganz anders aus.
Finde ich finde ich auch toll.
Das ist ja, das ist ja auch noch mal so ein äh interessanter äh Punkt äh dieses Lenzing,
Was erlaubt denn das im Prinzip? Also der Effekt ist ja der, man hat äh eine Galaxie oder irgendwas anderes, was äh extrem viel Gravitation hat im Vordergrund. Kann ja auch ein schwarzes Loch sein.
Was auch immer äh und dann man blickt,
Sozusagen dahinter auf eine Galaxie, die dann quasi um diesen Punkt am Himmel herum sich kreisförmig anordnen, ne? So kann man sich das ja vorstellen.
Also Kreisförderung gehen Idealfall. Also es nennt sich dann auch Einsteinring. Genau richtig am
Daraus kann man eben dann eben schon sagen, wie die Galaxie sage ich mal zur Vordergrundgalaxie platziert ist. Eben wie wie stark die gekrümmt sind oder ob das halt eben ein ein ein sogenannter Einstein-Ring ist oder wenn man nur gewisse Bögen sieht
gibt's halt eben auch äh Modelle, mit denen man halt das Lenzing halt eben vorhersagen kann. Dann kam halt eben suchen, ob dann an gewissen Positionen noch andere Galaxien sind. Aber der große Vorteil von diesen ist,
Natürlich wollen wir immer höher weiter gegen größere Teleskope, aber mit mit solchen Teleskopen kann man,
erreicht man zwei Sachen. Zum einen wird die Helligkeit erhöht und zum anderen kann man auch die räumliche Auflösung erhöhen.
Wenn man zum Beispiel einen Faktor 10gewinnt, also,
Zum Beispiel das WLT ist ja acht Meter und wenn du jetzt eine gelänzte Galaxie äh damit beobachtest, also ist ja dann,
Kommt drauf an, eine Helligkeit nicht, aber mit äh mit der mit der genau mit der räumlichen Auflösung, wer das müsstest, du bräuchtest so ein achtzig Meter Teleskop.
Das heißt, es ist besonders wertvoll eigentlich genau diese Stellen zu finden, wo so ein Lenzing stattfindet.
Genau richtig, also da sind jetzt auch in den letzten zehn, 20 Jahren wirklich in in verschiedenen noch Wellen in Bereichen starke oder na ja starke Bemühungen sind gemacht worden
Man kann auch was über Kosmologie darüber lernen
Aber andererseits hat man eben auch die Möglichkeit ähm Galaxien einfach besser zu studieren, weil man halt, weil die halt einfach heller sind und die räumliche Auflösung ist einfach größer.
Ich habe gehört, dass da äh vor allem jetzt Machine Learning äh verstärkt zum äh Einsatz kommt, um sozusagen durch die äh durch das Datenmaterial durchzugehen und diese Lensis dann auch automatisch erstmal zu detetieren.
Ja stimmt, also zum Beispiel jetzt kann man das auch im im Kopf äh während uns gerade während unseres Gesprächs gibt ja jetzt eine eine neue Mission, die Dark Energy äh Mission, die das ist ein Satellit, das soll halt eben die die dunkle Energie ähm äh vermessen
anhand vor allem zum Beispiel von Galaxienhaufen, da kann man ja eben dann was über die Kosmologie sagen,
Und da ist halt eben, sage ich mal, auch ein Produkt von von von diesen Beobachten ist halt eben auch nach äh Landsing-Effekten zu suchen und,
Und genau, also ich arbeite jetzt nicht daran an Machine Learning, aber ich habe das aber wie gesagt,
halt eben Kollegen, die das halt eben verwenden und allgemein in der Astronomie, Astrophysik, Maschinenlearning hat da wirklich einen starken Einzug erhalten.
Ich meine, es ist wirklich ein sehr angemessenes Tool, weil es natürlich also Machine Learning ist ja im Prinzip eine Technologie äh mit der man,
quasi einmal sich auf Daten, die sie auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise zeigen,
gut drauf trainieren kann, so nach dem Motto ich zeige dir,
tausend Bilder von solchen glänzten äh Sternenformationen und jetzt zeige ich dir nochmal tausend ohne,
so und äh das System weiß halt aha, da ist so etwas, da ist so etwas und kann dann so quasi diese Natur, dieser Anordnung in irgendeiner Form detektieren und dann nimmt man halt den großen,
Salat und äh Nudel, den einfach durch diesen Algorithmus durch und dann kann er halt sagen, ja guck mal hier, hier, hier, hier, hier.
Der, der Wahrscheinlichkeit ist an der Stelle was zu finden und dann hat man ja überhaupt erstmal wieder Ansatzpunkte, auf die man dann eben stoßen kann, sonst müsste man sich da ja alles äh in der nächtlichen Slideshow von Hand äh anschauen und finden und das ist sicherlich auch getan worden, aber ist natürlich extrem langsam im Vergleich zu so einer vollautomatisierten,
von daher passt das ja eigentlich sehr gut und wahrscheinlich gilt das generell natürlich auch für die Himmelsbeobachtung in Zukunft, dass solche Werkzeuge zum Einsatz.
Maschinenlearnings natürlich auch
Äh wie wie du ihm erklärt hat, das ist ein Tool, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass man da einfach nur auf den Knopf drückt, dann funktioniert das. Da braucht man auch eine gewisse Expertise und man lernt das auch nicht von heute auf morgen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel Doktorarbeit
halt wirklich dann die Leute jahrelang ähm darauf hinarbeiten. Also das ist schon schon gewisse Expertise also.
Aber ist halt im Moment also sehr populär auch in unserem Bereich, weil wir halt eben riesige Datenmengen ähm bekommen und da ist halt eben Maschinenlearning eine Möglichkeit, halt eben diese Datenmengung, also sinnvoll durchzuforsten.
Diese Clusterbildung von Galaxien, das würde mich zum,
nochmal interessieren. Ist ja auch noch so ein interessantes äh Phänomen und das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, auch so ein so ein so ein so ein Punkt, an dem einen die.
Ausdehnung des Universums auf bestimmte Art und Weise nochmal äh enorm klar äh werden kann oder zumindest äh schwer beeindruckt.
Wir schon Probleme damit uns überhaupt äh die Größe der eigenen Galaxie vorzustellen und äh es gibt ja auch noch welche, die nochmal sehr viel größer.
Äh sind, auch kleiner als unsere. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sind wir denn so im im Mittel, so ist unser wird bestimmt wieder so eine Durchschnittsgalaxie, oder?
Hätte ich jetzt schon gesehen. Also ein Trommeldalaxie ist nochmal größer, aber.
Nichts Besonderes.
Da ist unsere halt, aber das war's dann auch.
Ja, ich denke also auch von der von der von der Sternemaße und so sind wir schon im mittleren höheren Bereich, würde ich jetzt mal.
Okay, mittleren Hörerbereich ist ja schon mal ganz gut. So und jetzt,
haben wir unsere lokale Gruppe, mit dem wir uns irgendwie vereinigen. Es gilt also immer wieder eine weitere Struktur äh in in der dann doch nachweisbar ist
dass es in irgendeiner Form einen Zusammenhang gibt, dass diese Galaxie nicht isoliert voneinander sind, sondern eben in irgendeiner Form noch,
Durch Gravitation ähm einen Einfluss aufeinander haben und das ist ja dann auch teilweise ineinander verschoben, dass also quasi solche Cluster auch überlappen und,
nicht unbedingt komplett äh isoliert sind. Äh also inwiefern sind diese Cluster bei deiner Arbeit,
inwiefern spielen die eine Rolle.
Richtig, also diese die Galaxienhaufen.
Die leben dann auch nicht unbedingt alleine. Also diese Galaxienhaufen können wirklich wieder Teil von einem Supergalaxienhaufen sein. Wie das ja zum Beispiel auch äh ähm mit mit Virgoeben äh der der Fall ist.
Und richtig, um zum Beispiel jetzt äh mit dem Spider-Wap Galaxienhaufen, da haben wir jetzt eben auch ähm durch unsere Beobachtung mit dem Teleskop in Australien eben von dem molekularen Gas.
Gibt es eben auch eine Interpretationsmöglichkeit, dass es möglicherweise ein ein riesiger, ein super Galaxienhaufen ist,
Substrukturen hat, aber das sind jetzt
nur in Interpretation. Es kann auch sein, dass es einfach nur Filamente halt sind innerhalb eben der der größeren Strukturen, aber das ist eine Möglichkeit, aber es gibt auch zum Beispiel einen jungen Universum Galaxim, also ein super Galaxienhaufen, der nennt sich Hyperion.
Ich,
Arbeiter an einer Unterstruktur äh sage ich mal dran und da haben halt eben verschiedene Kollegen verschiedene Galaxienhaufen entdeckt in einer ähnlichen Rotverschiebung am gleichen Himmel und eine Kollegin hat dann praktisch gezeigt, eigentlich
die verschiedenen Galaxienhaufen im frühen Universum, die man kennt, die gehören eigentlich alle irgendwie wieder zusammen.
Also es gibt tatsächlich auch einen frühen Universum eben auch schon diese diese super Strukturen.
Mh. Okay.
Immer von von ins Große.
Du hast ja ähm hast ja äh auch selber Galaxien entdeckt.
Welche Star von deine Liebste? Haste eine? Oder was war die besondersste oder die.
Ja also zum Beispiel vor ein paar Jahren haben wir eine entdeckt und die haben wir Cosmic Albrau genannt
ja, die hat mir eigentlich ziemlich gut gefallen, eben wie die Struktur. Schaut er tatsächlich wie eine wie eine Augenbraue aus und das fand ich fand ich ziemlich spannend, muss ich sagen. War auch eine gelänzte Galaxie eben.
Okay und ähm den Namen habt ihr dann sozusagen ausgedacht.
Ja genau.
Schreibt man dann ins Paper rein und dann heißt sie so.
Richtig, ich meine genau so ist es. Also das ist ja das ist ja so ein bisschen vielleicht auch so ein so ein Fun-Faktor in unserem Job. Ich meine,
Ja, man kann, wenn man was Neues entdeckt,
Es gibt natürlich regularien wie Galaxien heißen sollen mit einer gewissen sage ich mal Telefonnummer, oft halt eben verbunden mit den Koordinaten.
Also NGC, irgendwas.
Ja äh das ist jetzt ein Katalog. Das ist einfach nur eine, wie soll ich sagen, Durchnormung, es stehen ja nix, die Koordinationen drin, aber zum Beispiel in meiner Doktorarbeit. Da hatte ich dann eben paar Galaxien entdeckt,
Haben wir jetzt auch gar kein Nickname gegeben, sondern die haben wir einfach MMJ und dann die Koordinaten. MM halt für Millimeter und halt eben für den für den äh
Koordinatenkatalog, den man halt
verwendet ähm wurden die halt so bezeichnet, aber später in gewissen Kollaborationen hat man haben wir halt einfach angefangen Spitznamen zu vergeben haben. Macht halt einfach Spaß und,
teilweise einen Titel im Apps direkt hin und manche solche von diesen Spitznamen, die Bürgern sich dann ein, andere Leute benutzen das auch.
In anderen Fällen nicht. Es gibt da zum Beispiel auch so eine gelänzte Galaxie, die heißt dann das Saurens Ei. Weil die halt eben so wie von dem Herr der Ringe eben ausschaltet und ach
habe ich jetzt vergessen so vor kurz, ne, weil der mich mit Lieblingsgalaxien gefragt hat, dass jetzt haben wir eine Galaxie entdeckt
ähm wir haben ja auch einen Artikel veröffentlicht mit einem ehemaligen Studenten von mir. Das war seine Masterarbeit. Und die hat
hat mein Student dann eben Seepferdchen genannt. Also es nennt sich jetzt Kosmic Sea Horse.
Und also wenn man jetzt einfach nur so hinguckt, ist es ein bisschen schwierig, das Seepferdchen zu entdecken, aber wenn man dann eine Illustration hat, ja, dann sieht man das schon, aber,
Genau, also.
Aber diese Namen fließen nicht dann irgendwie mit in so einen Katalog äh Eintrag mit ein. Dass das dann auch wirklich mal so festgelegt wird, dass das der Spitzname ist. Der hält sich einfach nur, weil Leute den benutzen.
Ja oder richtig, wir sind natürlich dann auch kürzer zu sagen als zu sagen, äh das ist die Galaxy SMMJ, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben,
sagt man halt dann und das sagt auch viel mehr was, als wenn man dann irgendwie eine Telefonnummer äh verwendet. Das ist halt einfach einprägsamer und.
Aber es gibt keine Möglichkeit, einen richtigen Namen in irgendeiner Form anzumelden, so wie Astriden und so weiter äh einen Namen haben. Es gibt keine Dannabbauer äh Galaxie oder so. Das wär's auch mal.
Ja genau ich dachte du willst darauf hin. Ja aber was wir mal gemacht haben ist vor ein paar Jahren, also eben auch bei diesen bei diesem äh Galaxienhaufen in in in Formation nenne ich den immer, also diesen Galaxieprotocluster, den Spider-Wap
Da haben wir dann eben die Galaxien, die wir dann im Millimeterbereich haben wir dann halt auch eine durchnummerierung halt gegeben von 1 bis 16 und die haben halt dann eben DKB genannt.
DKB hat halt was mit den äh Familiennamen von den drei Erstautoren zu tun. Und so haben wir uns halt verewigt und,
Wir sind tatsächlich auch in anderen Papers. Es sind halt dann die Galaxien genannt worden. Die Galaxie, wie ich auch gesagt habe, natürlich auch eine Offiziellenname, weil man muss.
Eben
zu Katalogisierung muss man halt eben offizielle Namen geben von der IHO wurde das vorher festgelegt aber manche Kollegen benutzen halt dann eben den Spitznamen.
Wie gesagt, das ist halt äh Teil von unserer Arbeit. Das ist halt so ein bisschen Fahndung. Wie gesagt, manche Namen bürgern sich eher ein und und manche halt weniger.
Wie auch die Antenne Galaxy, die ich halt eben äh vorher genannt habe. Also wenn du zum Beispiel googlen würdest, würdest du sofort was finden.
Die du auch entdeckt hast.
Die habe ich jetzt nicht entdeckt. Die wurde schon von anderen Leuten entdeckt, aber.
Okay, aber wie viel hast du denn entdeckt? Was fällt denn so raus äh über die ganze Zeit?
Ach, das habe ich jetzt nie gezählt, also weiß ich nicht.
Hunderttausend.
Hundert vielleicht oder so, also.
Also bei mir ist es ja auch so, es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten Studien durchzuführen. Eine eine ist halt eben eine statistische.
Große Service macht, wo man hunderte, tausende Millionen von Objekten hat,
Ein anderer Punkt ist, was halt ich eher mache ist deswegen bin ich jetzt auch bei einer kleineren Zahl von hundert oder so.
Ähm dass ich mir halt eben ähm ein Objekt halt dann genau anschaue,
Also ich habe halt eben auch viele wissenschaftliche Publikationen auch mit Kollegen, wo ich halt ein Objekt genau anschaue und dann wirklich,
detailliert halt eben diskutier, aber es gibt halt eben auch Möglichkeiten über Statistik halt eben, dann über Populationen, zum Beispiel eben von Galaxieren dann auch eben Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen.
Das war halt eben meiner Branche, also damals, wie ich mit meiner Masterwelt angefangen hatte, das war eine der ersten Fragen, die man halt eben von meinem Betreuer gestellt wurde.
Was möchte ich machen? Eher Statistik oder
einzelne Objekte, aber mittlerweile, wie sich eben, wie du auch mitbekommst, immer größere Datenmengen durch Musterungen und so. Also ich bin jetzt auch in in Projekten,
dabei, wo man Millionen von Galaxien ähm beobachten, von daher auch die Frage jetzt, wenn du mich in ein paar Jahren fragst, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mal hundert, sondern ist es dann eine Eins mit viel mehr Nullen, weil,
jetzt auch im Moment in einem Service mit dabei bin, der nennt sich Sharks.
Service, den den ich auch leite, einen Infrarotservice und da gibt's äh Vorhersagen von meinen Kollegen, dass wir halt 20 Millionen Objekte beobachten. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass alle diese Objekte neue Objekte sind, aber,
dass wir halt eben auf äh über dreihundert äh äh wie sagt der Bogen gerade halt eben 20 Millionen Objekte im im nahen Infraroten beobachten und
allein in einer Aufnahme, hm sind schon 500.000 Objekte da, also von daher könnte ich jetzt so sagen, ich habe vielleicht auch schon viel, viel mehr entdeckt, aber.
Okay, aber ich verstehe schon, aber du äh im Prinzip möchtest du gerne eine emotionale Bindung äh mit mit der Galaxy äh der einzelnen Galaxie aufnehmen, damit man weil man die halt so gut sich angeschaut hat.
Ja, das das ist ein guter Punkt. So sehe ich das auch ein bisschen, wenn man dann arbeitet man halt eben an einem Objekt wirklich ähm ja viel dran, um,
klar baut dann ob man will oder nicht halt wenn die gewisse Beziehung auch von daher tendiert man da auch immer zu sagen das ist meine, deine, wie auch immer Galaxy, aber das ist natürlich nicht meine deine, sondern das ist halt äh von allen und so aber ähm.
Na ja, ich denke, wenn man irgendwo das erste Mal hingeschaut hat, dann äh kann man sich auch schon ein bisschen was drauf einbilden. Ja, Helmut, vielen Dank für die Ausführung über die Arbeit.
Ja, vielen Dank. Ähm,
Auch dir, Tim, dass du mich da eingeladen hat und das hat wirklich äh super viel Spaß gemacht über mein Themengebiet äh zu sprechen und hoffentlich konnte ich jetzt auch also junge Zuhörer motivieren, Zuhörerinnen motivieren
auch Astrophysik anzufangen und vielleicht auch sogar eine wissenschaftlichere Karriere einzuschlagen.
Eine Menge zu holen in dem Bereich.
Nee, also es ist halt wirklich auf alle Fälle, also die nächsten Generationen, die wären wirklich tolle Teleskope zur Verfügung haben,
Und ja, ist halt einfach auch spannend, weil was man ja nicht vergessen darf, ist also man man.
Die seine Leidenschaft, was man hat, also wenn man ein junger Mensch war, Sternenhimmel interessiert einen, konnte man wirklich tatsächlich zu seinem Beruf ähm ja verwandeln, man man ist seine Leidenschaft, das,
der Beruf und dafür äh bezahlt zu werden ist jetzt denke ich mal auch nicht schlecht, also es kommt mir so ein bisschen so vor wie Sportler oder
oder oder oder Künstler oder so. Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen spannend, dass man halt sich auch ein bisschen selber verwirklichen kann und dass ich halt eben auch heute die Möglichkeit
hatte so ein bisschen zu erzählen, was halt auch unser unsere Arbeit ist, dass es halt nicht nur ist ähm ein Bild äh zu machen, sondern dass halt eben davor oder danach auch verschiedene Prozesse eben dazu gehören, dass man halt.
Dann zu den wissenschaftlichen Schlussfolgerungen.
Super. Vielen Dank und ähm vielen Dank auch fürs äh Zuhören. Hier bei Raumzeit. Ihr wisst, bald gibt's wieder weiter.